[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
a
sh
[Music]
he
a
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
n
Bo
[Music]
we had some fiery chess on day one of
the chessable Masters the 2024 Champions
chess tour kicks off will day two give
us just as much drama I think so don't
go anywhere game start in just a
few he's down a piece he's down two
pawns a couple of checks magnus's King
is going to dance easily out of them
take my queen and give me a new one
please he's losing now right into the
and they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 they made a big mistake
oh and the bar's going up this is an
absolute Gem of a game Wesley saw has
done it he's going in for the attack but
he's walked into Checkmate black can
play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
my God why arm
[Music]
in it's day two of the chessable Masters
the 2024 Champions chess tour is
officially underway he's grandmas da
niski inter National Master Danny wrench
da yesterday was a blasty mick Blaster I
think that's the scientific term for
what went down your biggest takeaway as
we head into day two blasting MC Blaster
I think you need to lay off on the on
the high technical jargon Danny just to
you know include all of the viewers but
that's exactly what it was non-stop
action incredible results we had such an
amazing menu of games to choose from and
guess what we have an amazing menu of
games to choose from today and there's
even more on the line that's right for
everyone who still getting a little bit
acquainted with the format yesterday was
the playin which is a Swiss tournament
everybody jumps in to the arena and it
gets wild of course some of the biggest
names and some upsets got their way into
to day to where now we have match play a
lot to talk about over the next 10
minutes before games get underway
including the fact that the matchups
you're going to see they were chosen by
the opponents meaning there's some drama
already you got chosen by someone how
does that make you feel feel we're going
to get into all of that in just a minute
but before we do because some of you
might have actually missed yesterday and
made a big mistake we're going to let
this uh this quick highlight reel let
you know what went
down the 2024 Champions chess tour kicks
off with the chessable Masters what
upsets and what interesting players turn
our heads today yeah white is going to
be lucky if he doesn't get mated the
queen and the dark squares are a problem
for that white king Bishop to D4 BL his
oh he blund Rook h3b can't believe it
and you don't want to prolong the
game no go what are you doing and now
he's worse he's undevelop his pieces it
just doesn't work by the way we can't
catch head Jose Martinez he's on five
out of five Rook D2 Rook D1 Knight C1
check and King B2 no it's over that's
itaro calculates it to the end play King
to d
d he must have misclicked oh my God de
Anon is apparently fing all the best
moves what an absolutely crazy
turnaround won wins and those are the
standings as you can see four of them
didn't even have to play today to do it
one of them played fantastic chess that
was Jose
Martinez of course at the end of the day
it was josam Jose Martinez the birthday
boy da he was on top of them all at the
end hikara Nakamura had his chances and
then blundered in such an
uncharacteristic way gave gave the
birthday boy a gift but uh da lots of
fun we saw we saw some of the dramatic
moments there let's talk a little bit
about the players who are now fighting
even further for their placement to get
into division one Let's uh let's bring
up the players of course as we said
we've got josam on top he was the he was
the only person who immediately has
already guaranteed his spot uh along
with the other players in Gold who got
there by via the format kind of a
rollover from the previous year Yan
pishi and isiri vladislav artimo and Sam
Sean but then we get into the other
players all of those names had to
compete in the placement your thoughts
about maybe who who was on the best form
da other than the guy who obviously won
the thing well obviously some of these
names we look at and we expect them to
be in the top 15 Wesley iaru alza fua
but first of all I want to highlight
Peter smidler P SMY
was in phenomenal form from the very
first game until the very last game he
dispatched so many strong players so
many younger players carrying forward
the older generation along with Ralph
mov and also Sam belara Hawkin Armenian
GM he's about 2600 but he's an
incredibly dangerous player Danny and
we've talked about it that 2600 swamp
those players are hungry to score upsets
and to show that yes we can compete with
the likes of ala fua and he car
Nakamura I love that and it's funny
because you you mentioned a couple of
names in particular Peter fidler peace
fitty his rap name don't call a comeback
but then he got chosen by sunville T T
Shakin so let's let's actually bring up
the matchup card and talk a little bit
about this because we really didn't give
it its Justice at the end of the day
yesterday it was a long day and a lot of
people were ready ready to go get some
dinner and some snacks Donnie and I
included but real quick reminder with
one of the slight adjustments to the
format every player you see playing the
white pieces David Anton hkar Nakamura
Ali Resa peruja svil tur tur uh sakin
and then of course Vincent kimer they
chose their opponents da of course that
make that makes a lot of people wonder
why in the world did Vincent kimer
choose Wesley so in fact he's the only
person who didn't get to choose his
opponent he was kind of stuck with
Wesley after everyone else chose theirs
yeah kind of reminds me of Middle School
PE uh when you know people would choose
teams and I'm kind of The Last Man
Standing but obviously it's a choice
between some pretty unappealing options
and if you're SEL teras aak and you're
not choosing Peter smidler because he's
bad or you think he's a bad player and
it's going to be easy you're choosing
him because the other names are even
less appealing not that Peter Sidler
himself is weak but I'm also really
interested in Dennis lazic versus hikaro
Nakamura Dennis lazic made a major name
for himself in Toronto uh he might not
have done as well as he hoped but that's
not going to be an easy game for hiar
Nakamura at all and it's interesting
because if we go in
order let's actually remind everybody as
we're looking at this how it went down
in real time cuz again it was a long day
yesterday the first time we had gone
through this format the players were
picking their opponents for the first
time here's what actually happened in
real time this is fascinating David
Anton went first remember he actually
tied josam in terms of total points he
chose Ralph MTO da which meant hikara
Nakamura going second of all the players
remaining chose Dennis lavic which left
svil t hakin with a choice between yuong
y Vincent kimer Wesley so or Oli Resa
peruja well then it makes a lot more
sense to choose Peter fither nothing
against Peter but if you're looking at
it that's what svil tah hakin was faced
with then Ali Resa peruja chose Yu yongi
which ultimately stuck Vincent kimer
with Wesley so so okay I I think we've
we've kind of broken that down done it's
fascinating right when you consider how
that how that happened with Anton and
then Hikaru all the matchups kind of
makes sense and if you're Vincent kimer
you're like man I'm stuck with Wesley C
right now yeah and I mean even for
deanan you have a wider choice so you
might be able to choose a slightly more
convenient opponent but Ralph mov is a
former 2700 fed one of the strongest
Blitz and bullet players on the site I
mean again it's very important to
emphasize Danton isn't choosing Raam Med
off because he thinks it's going to be
an easy match you just listed the other
choices and I mean can you can you
choose nobody can you choose Danny
wrench
like what what are you that early in
this show and that really that no it's
just because you're so good that nobody
wanted to choose you because it's
actually a compliment I hear you and I
think you know as as a commentator and
as a very kind person I know you you're
you're kind of already thinking about
Ralph mto's feelings at the other side
of that but I'm gonna be honest at the
same time da he did choose Ralph mov and
lavic did get chosen by Hikaru so those
players while they may understand
objectively it still might sting a
little bit and I love that angle as we
head in to today's match play and
speaking of that let's remind everybody
the Swiss is behind us what is ahead in
the format today it is two game mini
matches of course the time control it
remains 10 minutes plus 2 seconds per
move one and a half points wins a match
obviously that would be a best of two if
we're still tied of course we will head
to Armageddon reminder that the
advantage of having a great day in the
Swiss is that even if you lose these
matchups you're still guaranteed
division 2 ultimately in terms of the
overall season that is absolutely
critical because you have to give
yourself the best possible chances as we
go forward to remain in the hunt for
that grand finals golden ticket uh so
fascinating stuff ahead these two game
matches with armagedon tie breaks if
necessary is what we have in store and
uh before we go any further the games
are getting close so let's remind
everybody overall of what the format is
we want to continue to educate everybody
that while it is complicated it's also
incredibly exciting fixing big problem
album in chess where we want everyone to
have a chance yet still make sure the
biggest names will make sure that
they're not out of the hunt in the end
so here is our format explainer video
pay close attention because when Don and
I get back it's time for chess to be
played on the
board the year-long Champions chess tour
consists of four main online events and
one live final each event will begin
with a playin tournament open to all
Grand Masters and top finishers from
qualifying events 69 players from the
playin will be joined on the second day
by the four qualifiers from the previous
Tour event match play with 73 players
will then determine placement across all
three divisions division play then
commences with 6 days of Double
Elimination Brackets the last player
standing are your winners the winner of
division 1 qualifies directly the CCT
finals the winner of division 2 secures
a spot in division 1 at the next Tour
event while the winner division 3 is
guaranteed at least a spot in division 2
in each event players also ACR points
for the season long leaderboard the
final standings will decide who joins
our division one winners at the year
endend CCT live finals each regular
season event will feature a whopping
$300,000 prize pool while the final
eight players will battle it out for
their part in half a million dollar in
prizes at the final that's 1.7 Mill
million dollar for grabs in the 2024
Champions chess tour so tune in and
watch all the action as the best chess
players in the world compete to be
crowned the next CCT
Champion Peter fidler peace fitty as we
called him a bookshelf we've gotten to
know well ever since his debut
competition in the Fisher random World
Chess Championship back in 2019 and look
at that did you know a Hearthstone
Enthusiast I did actually know he plays
Hearthstone um I don't remember when I
had this conversation I think it was
2015 in jalar on a bus where Peter
Sidler was talking about Hearthstone
talking about all the other games that
he plays and he also mentioned back then
that Yan pishi was a big fan of DOTA so
wait you think these chess players
that's all they do no no no no no they
are very much multi-talented and I love
that when was Peter fidler ever
presented as a top player in a chess
tournament as a Hearthstone Enthusiast
that might be the first time ever and to
me that's a little more interesting than
being reminded of the fact that he's
also a many time Russian champion and of
course uh uh uh someone who's competed
in the candidates and of course has an
amazing chess career but also a
hearstone Enthusiast and I'll add to
that he's more than a Hearthstone
Enthusiast for those who don't know he's
very very good at Hearthstone I don't
know the rankings specifically not
qualified to speak on that but uh but he
uh he would likely take you to town in
Hearthstone so all right I think we're I
think we're getting set I think the
chess is ready to be played the players
are uh the players are here we're going
to be diving in to uh to to moves on the
game we're going to start with Wesley so
in and Vincent kimer and you know again
I think it's of all the matchups which
we are spoiled for Choice here da I
think it's one of the most fascinating
because it's the only matchup where the
higher seed got stuck with their
opponent everybody else had already been
taken off the board Wesley so was that
last kid standing in the Middle School
playground except in this case you
really didn't want to pick him yeah
that's exactly right and they actually
haven't played that many head-to-head
games I'm seeing two over theboard games
one in 2023 uh in to of Steel Wesley so
won uh Vincent kimer defeated Wesley at
the WR Chess Masters in dorf so I really
really like seeing these relatively
newer matchups even though Vincent is
now 740 F he just hasn't been at the top
long enough to be able to play a lot of
games against Wesley so so it's going to
be a new match Big opening experts both
of them are incredibly booked up of
course Vincent has been training with
none other than Peter Leo for many many
years and that shines through every
single move that he makes speaking of
moves that are made we've got some moves
on the board Danny and we're off moves
moves on the board in English that
quickly transposes into a Queen's Gambit
declined we'll see okay so a uh not
necessarily a tame line but a line that
avoids some of the weirdly complex
regoin if you will and some other stuff
so kimer going directly into the the
very concrete C takes D5 and E3 to
follow so your thoughts quickly on maybe
what he wants to avoid against Wesley or
or a specific line he has in mind well
this is called the Carl's Bad Pond
structure it's named after the city in
Germany I think where uh in the early
1900s uh this line started to become
popular and Bishop F5 is is its own
Island because white can play Queen F3
here and this is a line that has also
been popular now for many many decades
Gary kaspar Vladimir kramnick used to
play it in the 1990s Queen F3 the bishop
drops back to G6 white trades everything
on F6 and you get this incredibly
unconventional endgame which looks
really really ugly for black but because
black has the bishop hair and because
Black's Pawn structure on the queen side
and in the center is so incredibly solid
I think the current evaluation is
something like a minuscule Edge for
white and this is exactly what we have
this is a very very well studied endgame
Danny yeah and kimer goes right for it
with the move King to D2 designed to
then probably play Bishop D3 at some
point natural development but you
already highlighted the framing of this
position is going to be all about does
White's long-term positional Edge on the
king side pay dividends or does black
get enough kind of dynamic play for the
bishop pair as you pointed out this this
queenside Pawn structure normally
something that white wants to take
advantage of in a middle game with a
minority attack something where you
advance the B Pawn try to undermine but
with the Queens off the board so early
and the king in the center white isn't
looking to flex in the same way anymore
and so that's another thing that that
black has going for him is that the
position is very very solid without
having to worry about this minority
attack so I kind of like the choice for
Wesley probably he'd be happy with a
draw if we're thinking about match play
and then getting a chance with the white
pieces next what do you think about that
yeah the vast majority of players I
think are happy to adhere to that
strategy particularly Wesley who's kind
of a classically trained player uh he's
not used to taking too many risks with
the black pieces and especially against
someone like Vincent who's so solid um
and also kind of a player with a very
classical Peter leoes style um so Wesley
more than happy with you know kind of a
a low maintenance kind of draw but I'm
not suggesting that this line always
ends in a draw this is actually a very
rich strategical end game
and if white over presses black of
course also can win games in this
variation this is a rapid game anything
can happen but I like the way that
Vincent is handling the opening he gets
his Knight to G3 Danny he's fighting for
that F5 Square he's going to bring his
Bishop out to D3 and ultimately he will
try to entrench a knight on F5 so very
very rich very interesting endgame and
we'll see how it develops I love it it
is a rich and interesting end game but
guess what we have a rich and
interesting middle game to go check out
I don't know if I'm going to jump right
to it or if we want to go to the bird ey
view to take a peek and I'll let you
know which I'll let you choose which
game I'm talking about if you want but
uh it's I'm just gonna do it it's AAR
Nakamura versus Dennis lavic I'm
switching over and what in the world is
going on here lvic already with an edge
is black this is like a a reverse snov
gone wild x-rated
Edition I was going to say let me tell
you what's going on here you car is much
worse and I'm still trying to count the
pawns this is the kind of position that
you would want to get uh and you're at
least up a pawn you've got something to
suffer for but here white isn't even up
a pawn how did this happen in 12 moves
and how did this get so bad and
moreover lavic is threatening a crushing
check on F3 Danny he's also threatening
the move Knight to B3 so hi car's only
move here might might be Bishop to E2 I
mean why does borderline lost here okay
we have to go to the Batcave and do some
analysis I'm going to jump right into it
oh my go Miss knight3 Knight B3 wins the
game Knight B3 is is lights out Knight
B3 hits the rook and threatens F2 it
doesn't matter whether you take it or
not what in the world is happening
here lights
out hikaru's coffee hasn't kicked in yet
or he needs to turn off the pineapple
behind him to get rid of the glare
because he's clearly not seeing the
board in the way that hikaro Nakamura
normally does again I'm going to analyze
we have to back up and just see how we
got here D it was in English to start
for
Hikaru E5
A3 okay this is already kind of designed
to sort of flip colors you have this
reversed Sicilian kind of idea for white
with the with the C4 E5 Dynamic but
shout out when you see something weird
Okay already D3 D3 instead of D4 that's
normally the way you undermine the
Knight here right yeah D4 is the main
move and it leads to this very
double-edged end game e takes D4 Bishop
takes F4 D takes C3 I've seen this line
before um and white trades on d8 and
maybe hikaro didn't want to get an N
game this quickly but then you know why
are you going into this line Knight B3
by the way has been found Dennis lazic
win car's rook in the corner but your
point is well taken Danny after Bishop
G4 Dennis just plays this in a very
Soviet school boy way just trade on F3
get the D4 square and this is just an
awful position for Nakamura this is like
all the things you try to avoid when
you're when you're on the black side of
the Sicilian in these sikov structures
because again the fov for for black I'll
say only really works by you know the
fact that you're giving up such huge
positional weaknesses it only works
because of the other Dynamic
compensating factors that black gets and
so if you're just giving in this case
giving black all of these Tempe it's a
nightmare to deal with and black is just
already completely dominating on the
dark squares normally again that's the
light squares if we were to reverse
colors in his
fov and Hikaru just goes into The Fray
completely blundering Knight to B3 and
look at that it's a brilliant symbol for
those of us who do our game review and
Hikaru has sacrificed The Rook on
A1 this is absolutely insane da
sacrifice is a pretty flattering way of
putting it it's it's how I used to
explain you know to my coach when I
would blunder a piece in one move and I
would start even during the game I would
already start rehearsing the stories I
sacrificed it and okay the sacrifice
didn't work out no Hikaru is simply down
a rook here he has to find a way to
generate some counterplay the game is
not over he can put a knight on D5 Danny
he can push B2 B4 and he's going to try
to muddy the waters he's going to try to
make Dennis lazovic nervous but right
now I don't even see a way for white to
win that Knight he goes Queen H5 okay
but black and just Castle King's side
and the Queen on H5 is a complete paper
tiger and the Knight on A1 is
essentially going to evacuate through B3
I mean barring a miracle this game is
over yeah this is one of those things
that just blows your
mind and it does show that even at the
highest levels occasionally opening prep
can go wrong and and even just opening
understanding right not necessarily
appreciating the dangers if you don't go
for the main line which again to remind
everybody we don't need analysis but to
just quickly show that the only real
move here for white is D4 into this
forcing reverse V ofof kind of end game
Hikaru played D3 and the wheels have
just been coming off ever
since I
uh I I I'm my mind is
blown yeah this is you don't see this
every day you don't see this at all in
hear Mor's practice that's why we're so
shocked and of course the game is not
over and I would caution people against
against counting hikaro out I mean how
many of these impossible comebacks have
we seen this is the hikaro effect in a
nutshell no matter who's sitting in
front of him whether it's someone as
experienced as Dennis lazic or Magnus
Carlson people get really nervous when
they sense that they're very close to
defeating Hikaru in a big game but what
a big game this would be barring a crazy
Miracle Danny a victory with black over
Hikaru in game one that would really put
hikaru's back against the wall
especially because Dennis is so solid to
the white pieces he's a D4 player he's
really really hard to beat on demand so
I'm I'm shocked I'm shocked at this turn
of events where only 17 moves in and
hiar is missing a rook on A1 yeah
there's it's literally you you kind of
you kind of tune in and you tune in and
you go wait what how did we get this
position here uh Hikaru shaking his head
even further he understands that Bishop
F5 just doesn't work after G6 like
honestly I wouldn't be surprised if
Hikaru resigned here you can literally
see the the game the game status graph
below there showing that with D3 things
first started going wrong but then
Bishop H3 and uh and things just fell
apart okay hikaro is not going to resign
he plays Queen to G4 but this is a plus
five ad for black and we're not even on
move 20 not something you see every day
black is literally uper Rook for no
compensation and the only threat that
white has here is Bishop takes E6 and
then Queen takes E6 check and even if
that happens it's not the end of the
world for black but the most clinical
move here is Knight E6 back to G7 drop
the Knight back Retreat it to safety and
if white plays the move Bishop to G5
Danny you could respond with F6 and
actually in that particular instance
both of White's Bishops are hanging so
we're literally two or three accurate
moves away from resignation here but
this is sometimes where hikaru's
opponents tend to slip up when they're
winning and they sense that they're
they're oh so close here it's really
important for Dennis to keep his
composure and not kind of let Hikaru
back in the game not let Hikaru keep
extending this game and putting pressure
on his
clock 100% uh I I'm guessing that lavic
is up to the tap speaking as someone who
at one point was not up to the task
funny funny clip that exists somewhere
on the internet I want a rook against
Hikaru in some tournament long ago uh a
streamers event it was either a title
Tuesday or Arena Kings and I lost that
game so I have lost up a rook to hararo
but um who hasn't I don't think I don't
think Lo and I know I'm not alone in
that a lot of people have but uh I don't
think lavic will be someone who who
stumbles to that degree you point out
Knight G7 which is a very clear move to
find because it also just unpins the
pawn so it's both a logical move that
that puts the Knight who's currently
attacked to safety and immediately
renews the threat of taking the bishop
um at this point okay I will be
surprised if this game is still going
after move 25 I think Hikaru will
probably see great defense throw in the
towel and try to clear his head for the
allout attempt to win his black and
force Armageddon it's his only choice at
this point
I don't know I mean Dennis has been
thinking now for quite a while I'm
looking over at his clock King
h8 I don't love that move I don't
understand why Knight G7 wasn't played
that was a really easy move okay now
Bishop takes C6 F takes C6 and Bishop G5
and maybe you could try to stir the pot
a little bit I I okay I hear you but
again I think you're suffering from a
little bit of Hikaru bias itis there's
an Affliction for it you can see a
doctor about it if you really want to
want to get that taken care of I
actually love King a from a practical
perspective I just forced a trade off
the board you attack my queen I'm going
to play Queen to
D7 and you're okay if I play Queen D7
you can take A1 but then I then I get
F2 that's true Queen D7 but Queen D7 I
will play Knight to F6 and G the queen
takes C6 I guess then you can move your
knight out of A1 okay it's gonna it's on
the board yes you're right completely
winning black black the night and in the
end you're down a
rook a I can't argue seen Rosman video
that's a rook I'm gonna spare you the
screaming and Bishop F6 check simply
King G8 was a dead end so Hikaru tries
Knight F6 still fighting and not only am
I Afflicted with Hikaru bias itis but
it's just I'm I'm traumatized I have
been on the receiving end of so many of
these completely winning positions you
think that there is no way this is not
the kind of game where Hikaru is going
to pull out a comeback and then suddenly
you start getting low on time your
fingers turn to thumbs your hands start
shaking and you find essentially the
only way the only way bortnik and I
always joke about this we find the only
way to make things complicated against
Hikaru okay he succeeded in making this
a little bit dicey I would play Knight
C2 okay maybe Knight D7 can be tried
still going still trying still
fighting I would play night D4 give up
the pawn I mean I don't know maybe even
just save my Bishop I just want to get
all my pieces in the game and and remind
him that I'm that I'm up a rook if I'm
Dennis loic probably the biggest mistake
you can make as you said is to continue
to try to be perfect and get yourself
down to under a minute I think as long
as he plays quickly and has time on the
clock yeah hi car is open mistakes will
come back to haunt him but look at this
car just continues to play fast it
doesn't matter he's just going to keep
going but Knight D4 okay H5 and black
should
win if if this goes down as a Hikaru
comeback I I will have literally seen it
all at this point I'm getting I'm
getting old it's been 16 years here for
the old man in chess.com I just I don't
know that I need to stick around after
this if iaru comes back and wins this
oh no this was too much this was just a
full Rook the problem was that this was
literally a full Rook with no
compensation and this Knight B3 shot
that is just not the kind of tactical
sequence that Hikaru misses every day
okay lazic is too experienced of a blitz
player I think to let this one slip
Bishop H6 might be tried but okay Queen
F7 black is completely winning no lasc
has this completely under control at
this point I think hiar is smart not to
play Bishop H6 because his he
understands that no material makes a
difference here the only thing that will
help is keeping this thing as confusing
as possible but here comes I mean even
Knight F3 if we want to just like force
more pieces off the board another trade
yes I mean not to say that we can't
recommend a lot of moves okay like Queen
F Queen E6 makes sense because I think
he wants to double Rooks this will be
straightforward probably we should
switch what go ahead no I'm I'm just
sort of again I guess I'm just
traumatized but yes I agree probably
lazic has this in his pocket he'll play
C5 he'll finish this one
off it's hard to switch away from Hikaru
because you know it's like a deer in the
headlights right I mean I feel a little
bit Frozen to what we're witnessing but
the reality is Dennis lazovic is up a
rook Hikaru is going to need gonna need
to dig deep to keep his uh division one
in our first Champions chess Tour event
hopes alive uh and he he has to win with
black on command to force Armageddon but
we have another another matchup that's
also getting wild Ali Resa fuia with the
white pieces he chose his opponent in
yuong y and I think he has a little bit
more going on so I'm G to switch over to
that one and uh oh wait oi res looks
like he's about to put this one away da
Ali res is totally winning here he's up
two
pawns and this is just a matter of
technique I'm looking at some of the
other games which are also heating up
Tera hakin I think is out playing Peter
Sidler um in a crazy position this is a
Lopez where white
demonstrated such skill and such
knowledge of all the typical ideas just
looking at that game um in the mini view
was already impressive I think Peter is
in serious trouble here with his back
against the wall literally he's got no
space to maneuver look at that Queen
that's infiltrated A7 oh this is looking
dicey for
black Yong Y is uh okay you know there
are a lot of experts these days that
exist on the white side of these of
these very deep and come very deeply
prepared Spanish positions but he's one
of them he's one of the world's experts
and uh I don't know exactly where this
one went wrong we can we can analyze it
if it's if it's too your fancy but go
ahead what I'm just looking at on tone
versus mov another game that's heating
up uh but we don't have to jump around
if you want to if you want to stay here
hey I'm into what you're into here I'm
just like a kid the candy score I I I've
got it all you can go to chess.com
events Choose Your Own Adventure what no
me too I'm this is a really really
interesting round actually and I think
Sam Bell essentially has this under
control okay well let's let's head over
to the bird's eye view actually just so
we can take a quick peek and I will give
our not necessarily obligatory shout out
but the the reminder that you can go to
chess.com events and watch all of these
games yourself remember that every move
you see and the broadcast itself is on a
delay for fair play reasons of course
our players are on very very close watch
two cameras and all other kinds of
proctoring going on you don't get to see
the other views that we get to see and
the checks they go through but uh but
yeah what you're watching is on delay
but you see it in real time as far as
you're concerned
and I'm uh I'm looking at all of these
games da every game is
complex I I would bet we get five
decisive results I'm doing it I'm
jinxing it knocking on wood commentators
cures we're GNA have five decisive
results here in the first round oh it's
entirely possible I mean Vincent kimer
is struggling against Wesley so lazic is
going to win uh fuja is very likely to
win now the Anton versus mov game is
just a crap show it's a crazy position
position where both sides have now under
a minute I mean look at this and this is
a typical Ralph mov game Rook takes E3
was the last move sacrificing The
Exchange oh Queen takes E3 he has Knight
takes
D1 counter hitting the
queen this is this is crazy we're going
to have to analyze this a little bit
just to show how many pieces are are
Under Fire here he takes C6 first which
which makes sense but the last couple
moves here started
with white allowing Knight takes F2
rather than trading on
D3
wait what yeah no this is insane Knight
D3 was a crazy move by mov there was
nothing on
D3 I guess white didn't take it because
if Rook takes E3 followed by Queen into
F2 and Checkmate although funnily enough
white could have done this and played
Rook F1 this is what the engine says
that's a that's a hard move to
find yeah that is incredibly cold
blooded so he dropped back to D2 and he
sacrificed The Exchange in MF says no I
don't want your exchange I want your F2
pawn and then things got even
crazier
F1 Rook takes E3 again just remind
everybody taking was never an option
because Queen takes and queen G2 is mate
so Rook F1 met by another exchange sack
white gets rid of that monster of a
bishop on on uh C6 spying
G2 and
now I guess in the end we're just headed
toward a very peaceful and tame opposite
code Bishop ending so that's what
happens in
chess hey we know that chess is a draw
okay white is in the driver's seat by a
small margin but White's dark squares
are also kind of weak so I wouldn't be
so sure that this is just a two result
game I think it's essentially a one res
game we're heading in the direction of a
draw provided that Ralph mov does not
drop his C6 pawn and even if he does
even if he does and the Queens are
traded Bishop D4 takes C5 will'll pick
up uh the C5 pawn and that should be a
pretty easy hold for my medov this might
be our only draw because seear nakura
has lost to lazic just just in time for
Danny to say we'd have five decisive
results i' get my first commentator Jinx
of the day in and we're not even a half
an hour into the show you're welcome
whoever had that prop bet going um all
right I think okay we can go away from
this one Anton and mov will play this
one out I'm gonna I gotta go back to
okay never mind we got to go see the
final position lvic did get the job done
with black if you're just tuning in what
a wild what a wild game this was hikaro
Nakamura blundering early out of the
opening Ali Resa fua ultimately did
convert this position versus Yu Yong Yi
Wesley so won with black against vinent
kimer so that means we are down to just
two games left and that was the one we
were just on that's going to be a draw
okay and then we have Peter fidler
versus svil tah Hawkin and this one is I
was going to say a two result game this
was winning for sell I still feel like
he's got winning chances he's going to
be up Aon in this opposite card Bishop
end game with Rooks on the board both
sides down to 10 seconds Peter Sidler
trying to hold it he basically has to
keep his Bishop on the f8 A3 diagonal in
order to prevent Rook G check and f8
queen Rook C8 Rook
C8 Rook G8 and Rook C Rook G8 and Rook
okay I was wondering what it's over
Black's pieces are
overworked oh my gosh nothing Peter can
do he's overextended and he's resigned
what's funny is the move that everybody
would play Da was the losing move Rook
F2 check put the Rook on a square that
ultimately overwhelmed the bishop right
this is why you can't always just give a
check ultimately now the bishop was
overwhelmed trying to guard both the
Tower and the square and that's what uh
that's what led to the position falling
apart some forcing tactics and
uh I feel like that was over before it
even started what in the world is going
on here what that round I mean I totally
know what you mean it felt like it
started in already Hikaru was losing
like one minute into the round and then
boom Vincent kimer losing in that
relatively risk-free line with the white
pieces to Wesley so what a
round yeah just to remind you everybody
what happened so defeats kimer fuia
defeats yuong y lavic takes down Hikaru
Nakamura with black Hikaru really in a
tough spot now must win territory to
force Armageddon with black not not how
you draw it up at home David antton and
M up did draw the only games that proved
peaceful and Peter fidler went down to
sale Tah so OMGs or snaps is that a is
that a thing I'm still allowed to say
OMGs or snaps you most certainly are
allowed to say it I mean I think that
correctly captures the atmosphere of the
situation for Hikaru Nakamura that might
be the biggest storyline of these mini
matches so far a must win with the black
pieces which is actually some of the
most entertaining chests Danny that we
get as chess bands when a player needs
to win with a black pieces all of the
bridges are burned from the very
beginning of the game yeah crazy stuff
and we're going to get right into round
two but before we do let's get this uh
real quick instant replay action of what
happened in the moments that Wesley so
took down Vincent kimer the trophies
look at the
trophies look at the big the big sigh of
relief there from Wesley so slow motion
fist pump and who says chess isn't a
contact emotional sport Wesley
so giving us giving us the Tiger Woods
there d
oh that was man the emotion on Wesley so
oh my gosh jumping up and down yelling
the entire state of Minnesota heard his
yells after that win but um in all
seriousness big win for Wesley he takes
these tournaments very seriously he's
had an incredible track record in online
events Danny and showing that once again
here all he needs is a draw with the
white pieces in order to win his first
mini match the other person who only
needs a draw is Dennis L also with white
obviously there were other decisive
games but if you're just tuning in Where
Have You Been we have drama massive
massive upset with denn Dennis lavic
taking down hikaro Nakamura with the
black pieces to kick things off here on
day two of our placement stage we
started with a Swiss for the players to
get here now the players are fighting
for their division one placement
standing and lives if you will uh what
do you do if you're hikara Nakamura
right you started off on the wrong foot
now you're black you're looking to do
one of your sort of double Fe and ketto
hippo specials da right we've seen him
do that before to create tension and
confusion but the risk of course is
you're always taking on a dubious
position when you choose those types of
openings and the problem Dennis lavic is
not a good guy to face if you need to
win on demand you would much rather face
someone like parha makula like we saw
gukesh he needed to win with black to
keep Pace with the leaders okay it's not
that baram is bad it's just that he will
give you chances because someone like
maxu or even Oli res fua they don't
really know how to play for a draw
they're going to play for a win but
Dennis lavic he's a D4 player he loves
Fen ketto setups and he's just so solid
with the white pieces if you're hikaro
Nakamura you do need a Kings Indian
maybe a Dutch um or like you said Danny
maybe he'll just pre-move G6 and get
something unbalanced but that's just the
start of the process it's not enough to
get an unbalanced position Dennis lazic
can do tactics
too and there we see hiar
streaming if you want to go check out
his commentary I think he's on Kick this
morning we can actually see the fair
play camera his phone y uh dialed in
dialed in to uh to to to make sure that
the team has his full field of vision
under their
observation but yeah you're right lvic
is not the style of player you want to
go up against right he's like a what do
you want like a mini comy or something
right just so solid and and very
difficult nut to crack not someone who's
going to give Dynamic chess maybe that
backfires a little bit right because I
think from you talked about the nerves
perspective he's still a young player we
know what a giant hiar Nakamura is if
you're overs solid and you give black
too many chances that can also be
something that haunts you and you know
how much it means to particularly to a
younger player to defeat hikaro Nakamura
in any format even a seemingly
meaningless three minute game but
particularly a game on a bigger stage
such as the inaugural CCT event to kick
it off with a victory over Hikaru in a
mini match huge confidence boost that's
just big and so you're feeling nervous
you're feeling like you're right there
you're knocking on the door Dennis lavic
just essentially needs to pretend that
this is a one-off game right you don't
want to go through the mental calculus
of oh I need to draw so what do I play
just play chess just play your game that
is the best bet I think for Dennis lazic
and something tells me hikaro is he's
definitely not going to go gentle into
that good night he will pull out all the
stops to make this an interesting and
unbalanced game we are in for an amazing
round where Peter Sidler and Vincent
kimer are essentially in the same boat
but at least Sidler has the white
pieces yeah that's the difference and
that's the tough thing if you're both
Vincent kimer and hikaro Nakamura
respectively is not not just that you
lost da you lost with white so okay
we're going to get into those particular
matchups but the first one where we
already have moves on the board Ralph
meta taking on David Anton this is this
is the only matchup in this second round
of games if you're just tuning in where
the players are not facing must-win
territory they drew their first game
here we've got a very closed looking
French something that if you don't mind
I might take a
nap yeah I don't mind at all Danny you
won't face any judgment for
me no just just kidding there this one
has the potential to get spicy as well
it's kind of a unique looking French I'm
just going to quickly run through the
opening mov so we see that it actually
started with the kokan the E5 extended
allowed the bishop outside the pawn
chain which is one of the key
differences between this structure in a
traditional French is even though it's
closed Black's Bishop not blocked in
behind the pawn chain as it normally
would be the the infamous French bad
Bishop yeah I mean from a strategic
perspective black should be happy um you
have essentially as you said a french
with the bishop outside the pawn chain
it's a French player's dream but but
that doesn't tell the whole story
because the bishop on G4 in some cases
can actually end up as a bit of an
awkward piece for example if you play
Knight F5 in this position which is the
kind of stock you know typical French
move white could respond with H3 and
suddenly you're forced to give the
bishop up for the Knight because Bishop
H5 obviously runs into the pawn Fork G4
and if you have to give up the bishop
for the Knight okay I'm not sure you're
a huge fan of that and I think we're
going to see that on the board H3 Bishop
takes F3 Knight takes F3 David Anon will
probably put his Queen on B6 and we
might get a very very sharp middle game
here as Ral M medov tries to keep his
Pawn Center together and might even
sacrifice the B2 Pawn as he tries to do
that well he's going for it now because
he'll he'll have no choice but to give
up one of the pawns whether that's the
D4 Pawn or the B2 Pawn black is now
bringing pressure uh a very very dreamy
French position but as you pointed out
that lack of a light score Bishop can
also come back to haunt black in
different ways that's exactly right and
in the meantime I think we have a very
spicy position in lazic versus nakabo we
basically called it Danny hearu doing
exactly what we thought he would do Fen
ketoing his dark squ bishop and then
getting as unbalanced of a position as
humanly possible the problem is that
he's also much worse he's gotten an
unbalanced position congrats check you
know check the box but it's also plus
one in White's
favor yeah but this is what we said
right when you're facing must-win
territory as black you're literally
choosing between poisons right playing
Mainline Theory at the highest level
always allows for lines that are just
known to be forc draws almost in any
opening these days right I'm not gonna
I'm not going to be too General with
that but the truth is the reason you see
these types of approaches when players
are in must-win territories black is
because whether it's E5 what do you got
Berlin Sicilian you can get Rosal lios
and and all types of variations that are
very forcing even main lines of the
night or so you're kind of damned if you
do damned if you don't when you lose
with the white pieces to start a mini
match so I'll say this as far as mwin
territory goes I agree that hiar was
just worse but this isn't the worst
must-win territory he's been he's been
in before and the engine often
overestimates these types of structures
because now that hikaro has just played
the move E5 we have more of a king
Indian structure and Dennis lazic
actually does not want to allow this
close Center position which I totally
understand the computer often gives like
a plus one advantage but sometimes it
overestimates it it can be a little bit
myopic when it comes to Black's kingside
attack so Dennis lazic maybe he'll play
the move E5 here I'm really attracted to
the move E5 in this position because if
black has to play DT C5 and I don't
really see an alternative you get a
queen trade you get a capture on E5
Dennis laic is thinking exactly along
those lines this is the LX of being able
to make a draw you can essentially guide
the game in the direction that you want
A6 okay Knight be to D4 looks pretty
good I think if Dennis plays Knight back
to C3 Hikaru will castle queenside and
try to trade on his own terms I still
think that's an equal endgame but at
least you get a little bit more meat on
the bone there yeah I agree I'm goingon
to I'm going to quickly analyze what you
said cuz I think it's actually a really
instructive point in terms of how to
play for must win chess here in this
position after E5 a lot of players I
think would say okay if I'm only playing
for a draw it's okay for the position to
be closed but that would have been the
opposite of what you want despite the
computer saying white is doing great
you're giving black a free role in a
closed position to slowly expl expand
and maybe build up in attack so this is
a really really heads up play to not
allow the Clos position despite what the
computer says and to force the game down
a much more a much more just direct path
with the pieces being traded so
forgetting about the engine eval engines
love positions where you have space and
comfort I think that from a practical
perspective Dennis made the right choice
but to your point you know here goes
hikaro he's castling Queen side and he
might not even trade Queens if you take
here maybe he finds a way to just not
take the pawn and keep the Queens on the
board no but he did I mean E6 Queen D6
is on the board Danny and at first I I
was with you I think oh this is just an
equal end game but no actually I think
black probably has the upper hand um the
Queens are traded I I actually now kind
of have soured a little bit on Dennis's
position because why why because black
has this bishop on G7 that's an
incredibly powerful bishop and after the
Queens are traded White's got that pawn
on C4 that's going to be a long-term
weakness Black's Rook could even slide
over to C6 and remember that white can't
easily play the move B3 you would love
to play B3 and connect your pawns but
you're always going to experience
problems with that Knight on C3 so
Dennis is actually pausing here you know
I'm not convinced that he's so happy
with that end game I do think that he
should trade Queens here I don't think
that he should keep Queens on the board
because his King is quite compromised
but yeah he's got his work cut out for
him here hearo definitely has chances in
this end
game well as much as much of an uphill
task as it is to win on command with
black if you were to choose you know one
player in the world to have to do that
Hikaru was at the top of the list right
right obviously you think of Magnus you
think of Hikaru right after for a reason
so I agree with you the more we look at
it despite my my applauding of Dennis
not just going for the closed position
Hikaru is uh giving himself the best
possible chances look objectively white
should be okay here he only needs a draw
but the more this game goes hikaro is
going to defend this Pawn or maybe he'll
just take and really make sure that he's
got enough of an imbalance to squeeze
here I think he has to try as you're
saying Danny Knight takes G5 Bishop
takes G5 and Bishop takes C3 ruining
White's queenside Pawn structure of
course you're trading more pieces and
you're getting the game closer and
closer potentially to a draw and he's
got to figure out a way to develop his
Knight no Knight back to d8 Hikaru
feeling that no Bishop takes C3 probably
traded too many pieces for his taste but
this is a very artificial way to keep
pieces on the board Knight to D5 Bishop
to F4 and this is is already looking
pretty nasty for black he car taking a
huge gamble here and I think it's about
to backfire I think it already
has I agree I'm going to analyze what
you just pointed out because as much as
it did trade a few pieces I'm with you
that taking
here taking on
C3 ensuring that you now have enough of
an imbalance to play for developing the
Knight what's funny is I can also
understand hi car's perspective and this
shows you the difficult task of playing
for a must-win as black it's like what
was he choosing even this as much as
this is horrible for for white like are
you really betting that black is going
to win this end game I mean I I don't
know right so
from from the perspective of what Hikaru
was choosing this is why it's not ideal
to lose with white in the first game
yeah especially against someone like LC
I mean you can see how he's playing he's
just trying to get all the pieces off
the board and that's a surprisingly
effective strategy okay what do you do
now now you can't play C6 because of
Knight B6 check and Bishop F4 which
picks off The Rook on D6 White's next
move is essentially pre-moving Bishop at
four and I mean just visually you can
tell that Hikaru is in massive trouble
here he needs a big mistake from Dennis
he needs a an anxiety mistake from
Dennis in the next couple of moves if he
doesn't get one he's very likely to go
down in flames in this game as well
Knight F6 but okay oh Dennis has a huge
tactic here Bishop F4 four Rook D7 then
you take everything on C7 and you have
Knight takes F7 at the end of the line I
think he spotted it wow wow all right we
got to analyze that again we're going to
stay right here this is maybe hikara
nakamura's Chess Masters this is it if
if Dennis spots this bishop F4 Rook D7
DA's tactic everything gets traded on C7
and you sacrifice temporarily on F7 boom
goes the dynamite rookie seven and after
takes white has a rook and a couple
pawns for the two Miners and really is
in no danger of losing this end game
exactly this could be
exactly this could be what the doctor
ordered we'll see if lvic spots it he's
played Bishop F4 hikaro is on the clock
and he sacrifices The Exchange to avoid
this yeah but this is I mean this is
complete
desperation um Bishop to E5 maybe Dennis
can get away with that but I would just
go Rook E2 the Dennis lvic approach is
just to play practically Rook to E2
guard guard the B2 Pawn are you really
worried about Knight takes F4 G takes F4
absolutely not there is no reason that
Dennis should lose this game now in a
classical game in a regular Blitz game
in a title Tuesday he would be playing
for a win here with white he would never
uh accept a draw in such a position with
white of course I paradoxically it can
actually add some pressure when all you
need is a draw because that's when you
start feeling the nerves and you start
feeling the proximity to a huge result
but Dennis has to keep his composure has
to keep some time on his clock and I'm
voting rookie two and then get your
other Rook into the game Danny I cannot
fathom how black ever wins a position
like this he's simply down an
exchange
yeah I'm uh I'm with you although again
I've unfathomed it before and hi has
pulled it off but but in this particular
case it's a little different when your
opponent is also playing with house
money right they only need a draw it's a
lot easier to force something out of
nothing when three results are on the
table and in this particular case all
Dennis has to do is uh is strangle the
life out of the position okay he does go
for Bishop E5 which which was the best
move according to the computer although
it is a complicated one after
F6 well F6 Bishop D4 F6 Bishop d
the point is the pawn is
pinned and Knight C6 there's Rook a to
D1 this is actually what he was spending
time trying to figure out this is
filigree Precision for Dennis lavic he's
got this in the bag I mean I just he
cars out of out of chances Bishop D4 C5
is a is an attempt to deflect the bishop
but simply Rook ac1 Rook A1 B6 and maybe
you even have Bishop take C5 there just
like ending the game
I mean really anything at all should be
winning
here simplifying the position after Rook
A1 B6 Bishop takes C5 if everything is
traded and in the end black has to play
Knight C7 Here Comes Rook E7 and
uh Dennis
lavic is moments away from sending
hikara Nakamura to division two in the
chessable Masters our first event of the
2024 Champions Tour so look at the drama
look at what's going on I uh I thought
we head over to the bird's eye view real
quick just to take a peek oh he's done
it this do it let's do it simplification
kills the cat again or is it curiosity I
remain confused but Dennis is uh is
taking us down that direction we can see
we've got all five games underway go to
chess.com events if you haven't already
pull up all the games yourself so you
can yell at us in chat about the action
we're
missing
um I would go anywhere you want to go
sir let's I mean Peter siller's game is
really heating up Danton versus mov I
think Ralph mov is very very close to
essentially scoring a knockout against
de Anon um I also wanted to check the
Wesley versus kimer game where I think
Wesley has things under complete control
as
well um I can't even decide so many
interesting games
Danny so many interesting
games I'm with you well let's let's go
to Wesley so and and Vincent kimer just
to take a quick peek and remind
everybody that Wesley so was the other
fortunate player to have won with black
which means he only needs a draw right
now is white and he's probably just just
on his way to getting a win at this
point with a great a great starting
position okay G6 by Vincent he succeeded
in getting something resembling an
unbalanced position but it's essentially
unbalanced in one One Direction white
has an attack and black doesn't so in
that sense it's unbalanced um F5 in this
position looks really juicy basically
just going for checkmate no but this is
just terrible for black super simple uh
it's looks like a great starting
position for Wesley he plays it without
much thought also milking a little bit
of a Time advantage that's the kind of
thing you like and
uh and we think we think Wesley so will
get at least a draw here let's head over
to the I guess the next biggest name in
the game after Nakamura and so you think
of fuja perhaps here Ali Reza won with
white only needs a draw with black this
one is is a little more double-edged
those uh those pawns have extended from
home here so maybe y e will have some
long-term chances if this can get under
time pressure yes I mean he's got this
diagonal he can drop his Queen back to
D3 on the other hand black always has
Bishop F5 can even play Bishop F5 in
this position and in fact that's what I
would do um just go for the bishop trade
no but this is a completely equal
position I think I agree the open King
maybe affords white some chances in
let's say a bullet game but Ali Resa
with three and a half minutes I mean
queen G7 is possible Bishop F5 maybe
runs into Queen D5 check um and I would
guess that that's what he's calculating
but no this is I think kza has this in
the in the bag as well I I don't see
yuang G pulling out a win
here yeah super tough position to create
something out of nothing again what you
wish you could do is just keep the exact
same position and get both players under
a minute right as da said in a bullet
game it's a lot harder to navigate the
potential tactics when your king is
completely naked over here on the king
side but with this much time you would
think Oli Reza will find enough accurate
moves and if those Bishops or Queens get
traded if either either of those get
traded and we head toward a major piece
Rook ending just over so all right we
quickly Flash the position wait just to
get an update yeah Dennis lavic still in
complete control against a Nakamura that
Brook on H6 is ugly AF no that's it B4
this is a winning on the spot because B5
is coming hikaro cannot prevent his his
minor pieces from getting entrapped on
the sixth rank he's resigned lavic wins
the second game wow what a result two Z
he didn't even need a draw he just
crushed Caro out of the opening two
games in a
row takes a confident Swig of water we
always joke players only do that when
they're winning and it's going their way
a chess player's favorite thing to do a
confident Swig of water Dennis lavic the
youngster continuing to make a name for
himself gets the job done against hikaro
Nakamura the
legend jumping to the next game we
haven't looked at we have this is over
this
is what happened in this game I saw
black king was on B65 moves ago and this
doesn't look any
better well we kind of called it Danny
it's the lack of the light squ Bishop
for black that paradoxically enough is
responsible for black not being able for
instance in this case what you wouldn't
give to have a a light squired Bishop on
G6 or on E8 right de onon is I mean
collecting pawns on the queen side while
Rome Bur Queen takes F7 and Rook B1 I
mean this game is a couple moves away
from just ending in total devastation
for the Spanish grandm who has this
incredibly risky style so he does lose
games like this from time to time Rook
B1 immediately this is also good it's
resign time for deavid and he's got less
than 20 seconds to go with it quick yeah
quickly keep it going but yeah Rook C2
just picks off the bishop at any moment
you can could probably take F7 for a
good measure but uh perhaps the human
thing to do is he doesn't even want to
risk it he plays Rook C2 the bishop is
going to fall we expect the final
moments of this one to be
near DAV Anton is uh is like well that
backfired you know really wish I had the
light squared Bishop right now and he
lets his time out it's over it's
over time runs out we go back to the the
well there's two matchups still going
Wesley so and Vincent kimer Yu yongi Al
Resa fuia mov has sent Anton to D2
division two lavic has sent Hikaru to
division two and
uh there's also the Sidler game Danny
yeah the Sidler game as well I actually
don't have that up right
now okay we can I think it's it's one
down
struggling a little bit to get that one
up we're going to stick right here or
let's go to the Wesley so kimer game
while we get that get that figured out
but okay well what's going on here
what's going
on whoa I'm trying to get my bearings
here Vincent kimer Vincent kimer has
managed to create some counterplay Danny
look at this he's got a rook on8 wait a
second this is actually getting a little
bit too dicey for so's
taste yeah definitely Dynamic still a
three res position which is all you can
ask for when you're in musn
territory accurate move from Wesley
accurate moves from Wesley include
moving the queen to E2 E3 E2 wouldn't
have been ideal because of Knight to
D4 okay Bishop f8 is a great move by
Vincent to stop Queen H6 which would
have traded Queens Dan
uhoh uhoh Queen H4 is a m threat Vincent
has to play King G8 I think and meet
Queen H4 with Queen D4
check he can't play Queen D4 check
immediately because then F7 will fall at
the end of the line no Vincent has too
little time I don't think he's going to
make this
happen yeah this is this is looking Grim
for Vincent he's got 40 seconds on the
clock King G8 was forced Bishop E3 what
a patient move by Wesley so bringing out
his Bishop but Vincent kimer he's still
fighting finding move after move to keep
this game going and keep the position
unbalanced all right it's imbalanced
he's under a minute apologies trying to
get this figured out so we can also take
a look at the filer game if we want
although if this one's interesting
enough we can stick right here your
call um
can we quickly check the position in
yeah let's do itler T just to get our
bearings reminder Peter fidler has to
win this game as
white I mean from an objective
standpoint this is probably closer to
equal Peter is okay material is equal
but look at the clock situation Tera
hakin with only 11 seconds basically
playing on increment but it is a pretty
simple position I feel like black yeah
black has a pretty clearly defined plan
of action here we've got a trade on D6
oh Rook takes D6 is excellent hitting
the bishop on A6 and Rook D4 W walked
into the fork but as you pointed out you
hit the bishop so there wasn't an option
now Rook D4 look at this what great
technique here with no time on the clock
by sell bringing the Knight to E5 is
just just good stuff yes Knight F2 was
also a
move okay we can can also go back to the
Vincent kimer game I feel like sell has
this under control he should not lose
this position with such an active piece
tandem although if he if he lets it slip
a little bit I mean white has this
two-on-one advantage over here I mean a
pass Pawn is uh is in in Peter's future
for sure and if he can keep the time
Edge I don't know I just have a feeling
I just want to stick here for a few more
moves to see if things things get things
get wild for Peter I don't want to count
F out yet you know I've done that then
he released that album right after
that's right and called you out in that
album E5 by Sidler his only chance
White's only chance is that past C pawn
and there it is right he's pushing C4
he's going to try to squeeze his King
into D4 but King C3 might run into Rook
A3 check and I don't think the Rook
trade is beneficial for white Rook H3
what a devilish idea by Peter but his E5
f is so weak it's so weak and it's
dropping the most likely result here is
that Sidler loses trying to win right
because obviously a draw is not helpful
okay he's got some imbalance but there's
twoo few pawns on the board I just don't
see him generating any practical chances
here Bishop
B3 okay maybe start pushing the H Pawn
and hope for a blunder but no this is
not going to
happen yeah okay well it's it's it's
difficult to choose in the moments but
we think sell should at least get a draw
here so we're going to head back to the
other game that is still well there's
two other matches going ala peruja
versus Yu yongi Wesley so Vincent kimer
let's go to the Wesley game I think you
I think olza has it in the bag but look
at this this is actually a little bit
double edged no but Wesley also has it
in the bag he's got too too much time I
think and two too many
pawns too much time and too many pawns
you
know how I how I often feel and not not
with the
advantage you know my my opponent has
too much time and too many pawns what
happened here um another
Pawn Wesley's just going to keep
grabbing at this point he could even
consider taking B7 and pushing F7
unnecessary they just agree to a draw
apparently kimer throws in the towel we
quickly head over to Ali Resa fuja yuong
y yeah looks like fua at least drawing
this remember that's all he needs my God
I don't think the players got the memo I
mean Dennis lzc needs a draw he wins
Wesley so needs a draw he plays for a
win ala fuja needs a draw with black and
he's essentially outplaying his opponent
he might decline a draw at this point
Rook to D3 and black is winning very
straightforwardly here Rook D3 and King
D4 and I think the pawn end games are
going to be winning for black let's see
how alza finishes it off wow Sidler is
still playing whoa OE res gives up the
win but it's still a draw yeah I was
going to say it the EV Valar gives you a
heart attack and then you remember the
match situation all fuja needs is a draw
so that was the very the very practical
thing to do uh really nothing yuong y
can do he might even just accept his
fate right now looks like he's about to
indeed he does so we quickly go to the
last match up again Peter fither is
still playing whoa whoa whoa whoa and
black has to give up the for White's
remaining Pawn if Sidler can get to
black two pawns you get rook and Bishop
versus Rook but can he do
that well look when your opponent only
has five seconds they are quite
literally living off the he's bled one
of them here we go Peter Fiddler peace
fy's do it but can he get to that last
Pawn Danny in my experience when you
have a situation like this with that
remaining F Pawn it's actually very very
hard against proper defense to actually
win that pawn yeah Peter is trying
though and that's the right attitude if
you're black you shouldn't settle to
just well King and Rook versus King rook
and Bishop is a draw you should do
everything you can to hold on to that
pawn and just make it impossible you're
more likely to get a repetition right
here honestly and as we've always said
it's very hard to hold that end game
with no time and at some point you could
even sack your Rook for the bishop on D5
but you don't want to rush it King H3
and I think you can do it now Rook D5
Rook D5 and King G2 is a draw he's
calculating it and he's going to do it
he's going to do it he sees it Y and
he's done it sacrifices The Rook that is
a heads up play Peter Fiddler's division
one hopes come to an
end and
that is our first round of match play in
the books that's how you have it to svil
tah hakan moves on Dennis lazovic moves
on Ralph mov o Resa perua and Wesley so
all move on to the next round and uh and
yeah a very nicely made bed looks like a
hotel room definitely is a chess
player's
life wow what what a series of matches
Danny that was amazing I I honestly
would ask you normally what was your
what was the biggest surprise what was
your biggest takeaway I think I know the
answer but go ahead and take it away
anyway well Dennis lovic is the man of
the hour winning that first game right
out of the opening demonstrating such
Precision such control technique it was
never out of the question and then in
the second game not just trying to play
for a draw but actually playing
aggressively and Out playing Hikaru from
that equal end game to take the second
game as well but also a spotlight on
Ralph mov he's one of my favorites he's
got such an enterprising style so
Dynamic and such a difficult opponent
for anybody to face he advanced ances
with a sparkling victory over de Anon in
the second game of their match ala fua
he takes care of business and so does
the Armenian GM who by the way I pointed
out yesterday really early in the
tournament Samuel Tera Hawkin don't
sleep on him because he can score some
upsets especially in Rapid chess he's a
guy who made a name for himself in the
proess league over the last few years
someone who just with an aggressive just
uncompromising style when you don't have
a lot of time on the clock he is a pain
in the rear to face uh Again David Anton
chose his opponent in Ralph mov as hiar
Nakamura did so as far as higher seeds
who might be regretting their choice a
little bit those are the two that go
down ultimately Wesley so was last
picked for a reason he showed he showed
why nobody wanted to play him and he
took down Vincent kimer so okay uh
amazing stuff match play will continue
the drama is already very real we're
going to take our first break here in a
second but in in the meantime four-time
us Champion Yasser S one yeah exactly
exactly I'm throwing to a Yasser
reference here he's got a new ches
course out he presents his own winning
chess strategies on chess a book that I
read as a kid which was absolutely
phenomenal you should check it out
there's Hikaru in the final moments but
we're going to take our first break when
we return it's more match play the
chessable Masters continues in a
few
[Music]
e
me
our once magnificent Kingdom of Chess
lays now in ruins our King slain but
some say that a new ruler will come and
restore the realm to its former glory
solve puzzles fight epic battles and
earn gold swords and Scrolls full of
Chess wisdom on your way to reclaiming
the throne download the app today and
this month only face off against your
favorite Kingdom character Bots only on
chess.com
[Music]
hello can I get 50 L back please because
one of my friends played on my account
and lost 50 thank you I've got friends
like that too when I'm frustrated or in
a bad mood something strikes maybe a
little bit you know what maybe a little
maybe you know I don't know it's been a
good night
yeah now I have friends just like that
man they they come on my account I wake
up in the morning yeah well the good
news is um better to have friends who
lose you rating points than gain you
rating points because then your account
might be closed for cheating Pro tip I
am deeply sorry for the language I used
I will never ever ever use vulgar
language again I'm sry please unburn me
please you are my star and my sunshine I
go to bed dreaming of you and when I
wake up I think of you again so I ask
kindly please chess.com come with me to
pom hugs and kisses we wub you too
unmute that man we wub you too I wub all
MBL I feel like we were being taunted
just a little bit there um but at the
same time I'm not one to judge anyone's
speech impediment you know and so
welcome welcome you whisky wabbit I
don't know what else to say and it's a
gaming site you know with people write
in and they've got the right sense of
humor it means a lot to us cuz you know
that's that's the kind of um The Vibes
we
want
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
we are back the first match play round
is in the book some amazing upsets some
incredible games D nitki here alongside
Danny wrench taking you through day two
of our placement round here in the
chessable Masters but all right
we're in day two there's also a division
two and a division three going on
there's so much chess it's impossible to
follow so just like yesterday we had
Grandmaster David Hal we are now joined
by International Master Tanya Sev you
know her you love her she is the host of
so much that the champions chestor does
and right now she's gonna help us keep
an eye on some of the games we might
have missed in the other divisions go
ahead Tanya hi Donny Dan I'm so excited
to be here we started yesterday and it
was quite a banger we had so many
turnarounds in the end and we seeing so
many turnarounds in division 2 and three
as well you said I have to review a game
but I'm going to try and quickly review
a match cuz this was all kinds of
shocking and the one that I want to take
you guys to is from division two it
really matters to these players to stay
in division two it gets them a chance to
get to division won so much money on the
line and this is the match that I want
to show you guys uh it's shimanov versus
antipov uh and it starts this position
is where I'm going to start from because
this position really complicated I was
following it and white
is down upon but look at Black's King
it's in the center white has all this
peace activity the Knight on G5 and the
Queen on C4 makes sure that black can't
castle and get the king to safety and
now shimanov makes this move uh jumping
in with his Knight to C5 a really nice
move and here antip played Knight B6
hitting the queen and then disaster
strikes no this it it was shocking I was
watching this SL so you can just imagine
yeah this happen and here makes the move
Queen to
A4
[Applause]
and of course that happened it happen
it's a one move a queen drop a mouse
slip and of course anti immediately
gobbled the queen up white has got four
minutes on the clock absolute heartbreak
and now shimanov has got the task to
make a comeback in game two with the
black pieces and I want to show you a
really quick moment about how he managed
to do do that because again it was all
kinds of
impressive so I'm going to just quickly
pull that up Queen A4 I mean Mouse slips
it's kind of really difficult to get
over that no mindblowing just insane and
this is the position that I want to
bring your attention to now in this
position shimanov playing with the black
Pieces Just out of a fresh Mouse slip
blundering a queen uh his opponent makes
the move C5 trying to open up the sniper
of a bishop I really liked this move
even though it's a cross I think from a
from a practical perspective these kind
of moves are really dangerous uh after
C5 white black decides to capture the
pawn and just ignore all these computer
evaluations of good move bad move
because it's a really complex position
right and shimanov in a must-win game
here white takes back the pawn the
Bishops open and after F6 black uh
shimanov simply blocks down the diagonal
hits the Knight but notice how the
Knight actually cannot be taken because
Bishop takes Pawn would then be a check
winning the queen lots of arrows but you
get the point which is why white
continued with the move Bishop to B5
attacking The Rook black simply s
stepped and I think this was the
critical moment here because shimanov
played such a sneaky move it was a
little move but with a big threat King
to G7 and again notice how the computer
gives this across but from a practical
perspective I was really impressed with
this move because it sets up a really
big trap which is so easy to miss and
you're going to understand that in just
a moment because antipov also missed it
he made the natural looking move here
lifting his Rook up one square simply
moving away from this spin but notice
how now the bishop the King on G7 and
not on h8 does a really nice job of
actually defending a key F6 Square so
now it was possible to grab the piece
Bishop takes Pawn the Knight comes back
and it's defended by the king in the
earlier line white could have moved the
queen to G5 attacked the Knight and the
tactics would have worked out in anti
pu's favor but because of this sneaky
move King to G7 which the computer
didn't like shimanov actually ends up
winning a piece in this tactical
Skirmish it doesn't work because now
white can't take the queen anti pu's
Queen is attacked and all the tactics
work out in antipov in shimano's favor
eventually it went onto an Armageddon
which again had big tactics and shimonov
was the winner of this match a queen
slip King to G7 in game two setting up
the Trap and eventually taking the match
against uh antio it was quite the
comeback one wow honestly I I just keep
going back to the mental fortitude to
recover from Queen A4 like that is
that's that's pretty pretty mind-blowing
stuff there to blunder a queen in
literally one move and come back and win
so all right awesome stuff Tanya I know
it's been wild it's Furious but we're
back here on the tour are you are you
excited you've been a you've been a fan
of what's happened so far I'm super
excited I loved day one and the action
that's on in the plays as well not just
in division one but there is such
exciting games in division 2 I've been
talking about The Comeback Kid shimo
well kid I don't know if I can call him
the comeback kid but the comeback player
but it's not just him Jeffrey Jong made
a comeback in his match Alexander
grischuk made a comeback in his match
Daniel dubov in division 3 made a
comeback in this match and that's what I
love about this format it's just so
unpredictable I'm really excited
Danny I love it Tanya great to see you
of course you will have the action
starting tomorrow with David how and
Robert hes so we'll let you get back to
it you'll keep an eye on division 2 and
division three for us Don and I are
going to move into previewing the
pairings of our next round and we'll
catch up with you in a little bit see
you later and good job guys I'm on the
edge of my seat I'm G to be following
the action see you
later bye Tanya all right da by Tanya
all right da apparently that rhymed
let's take a look at our matchups here
the players still standing we also had
opponents chosen by the top seeds from
what I understand and once again as you
see them Martinez nepon Mishi giri artv
all chose their opponents which makes
sense why Sam seian is stuck with
Wesley's
help yeah what an easy pairing and
Dennis lazic versus Anish G can Dennis
continue his Cinderella run um against
one of the most solid one of the most
consistent and unup setable players in
Anish giri literally and figuratively
and of course the matchup of the two
dark horses Jose Martinez versus S vter
sakin Ken Jose the birthday kid now 25
years old can he continue that
incredible run from yesterday that form
man going to be going to be interesting
to see again what one thing that I'm
wondering about you just mentioned form
let's remind everybody that other than
josam the guy who was in great form
yesterday we don't know whether yomi
Anish giri artv and of course Sam sevian
are going to be on form yet the moves
about to see are their chessable masters
and their 2024 Champions chess tour
debut uh they've been on the sidelines
eagerly awaiting perhaps feeling really
good about the fact that they got a
preceded spot given how the format works
but uh but no more no more watching no
more waiting it's time to jump in and uh
we'll see if npom Nigi and the likes of
all the other players who are joining
for the first time we'll see if they're
on
form yeah it's hard to say is it a good
thing uh to have that extra round of
rest or uh do you prefer to actually
play because you're more warmed up
you're more you know you're more In the
Heat of the Moment so there's different
schools of thought but either way uh the
work is cut out for sville Tera Hawkin
Jose Martinez has some incredible
opening preparation which was on full
display yesterday and this delayed
alipin that he starts with he's been
playing this move almost exclusively
this line with h three and he knows it
extremely well it's actually hard to get
out of the opening against Jose in a
decent position when he plays this
delayed
alipin agreed and it's it's a it's a
weapon we've already seen him get some
quick wins in I think s tah hoaki and as
all the other players are there he's
aware of this being a system that josam
is going to play but uh that doesn't
mean you're you're any more ready to
deal with it it's not it's not a system
with a ton of bite it's not like white
is getting some sort of really deeply
prepared Theory or or a position where
black can misstep with one move but
overall it's a position that josam tends
to know better than his opponents and
that pays off especially in fast time
controls and you can already see it here
moving instantly and I like Sam Bell
setup broadly speaking these pawns on C5
and E5 it might create a bit of an
awkward impression but at least he's
preventing Jose from grabbing control of
the center with D4 but clearly josam
still in his prepar he trades on F6 so
he gives up the bishop pair but he gives
it for positional considerations he's
got the light Square control um that
light squ Bishop is on a really prime
location the Knight Ru Lopez style as
you're showing Danny this is a very R
lopezes structure and svel I think has
to compensate by orchestrating some
kingside play Maybe moving his King to
the side and quickly trying to play it
King's Indian style with F7 F5 I
actually love the way the Armenian GM is
handling this
opening I agree I I was going to say we
we're complimenting Jos buum he plays
these systems as white he's still
playing quickly so you would you would
you would assume in some level of prep
but I actually love Black's chances in a
position like this because yes white has
this positional Advantage as as we you
already highlighted a very ruy lopezes
Advantage But Here Comes black black has
the bishop pair black has a structure
that easily supports expansion on the
king side and if if you're looking for a
three res position this is what the
doctor ordered and I'm I'm actually
thinking that sell can't be unhappy at
all about the opening in this game well
hopefully Jose wasn't out too late
yesterday it was his birthday uh he did
have plans to celebrate with his family
and his friends um but we'll see I mean
Bishop A2 clearly white Was preparing
the move B2 B4 expanding on the queen
side samvel says not on my watch he
pushes A5 and the typical reaction for
white here is to play the move A4 and to
seize control of the B5 square but I'm
just worried for Jose because the queen
side is not where the party is happening
it's not where the action is at so white
can control all of the squares to his
heart's content but if you get
checkmated on the king side I mean all
of the squares that you control in the
center and on the queen side are going
to be a mood
point I'm highlighting what it looks
like not just because you know I love
coloring books but because if you you
may not even want to play a for right
away but the point is if this was
position becomes a king's Indian type of
Affair where black has a free role on
the king side because we're super locked
up this can get very dangerous very
quickly of course White's intention if
black all in commits which okay we're
going to see it is probably to try to
orchestrate a strike in the center to
undermine the structure often the best
defense against a flank attack is to
open the game pro tip for anyone
watching but I'm I'm excited about where
this is going to go this is about to be
one of those kind of games that just has
you on the edge of your seat black will
be over here and and white is going to
have to organize defense while trying to
open the center to undermine Black's
attack we have a very exciting game in
mamea versus nepi which is a really
interesting match that I just wanted to
Spotlight Danny because those two
players those two players have faced
each other an inordinate number of times
most recently at the 2023 World Cup
where they drew their first two
classical games Yan pishi won that match
by the hair on his chinny chin chin and
he doesn't have a lot of hair on his
chinny Chinchin they've also played at
the 2022 World Blitz Championship 29
World Blitz Championship they first faed
off in the
2005 World youth Stars which is a
Scholastic tournament so these two
players have known and faced each other
for the longest of times and they always
get these crazy tactical games obviously
nepo mov both are incredibly sharp
players okay first impression is that
Ralph might have bitten off more than he
can chew his Center is kind of
collapsing here Danny what's going on
such a wild position we need to analyze
this just to see how we got here because
I'm looking at a pawn on C5 and you know
the the the the D Pawn wasn't Advanced
to get there I'm kind of like what what
happened here we've got this we've got a
sicilian a Rosal liimo mosa type of
variation which is where the bishop
comes to B5 whether the knights on C6 or
the pawns here that depends on whether
it is named rossal Lio or or Moscow but
after a kind of a a tame looking
approach the position gets super wild
here after black gives up the bishop
pair and white just strikes with B4 Rook
G8 What an what an ambitious move to say
that you can just attack the white king
and neglect your king in the center and
Neo's like okay you're not going to
Castle where well uh here comes the heat
right I'm just going to blow open this
position I I think this one could
backfire very quickly for Mya this looks
very very SP
first of all I think having said Peter
you have to say Paul he's got to go G4
and basically go all in because if he
plays D C5 now the problem and we can
put this on the board D takes E5 E5 and
White's Pawn just acts as a battering
ram just just slashing through the
position for example Knight to D5
E6 and I mean just look at how Black's
position is completely destroyed by this
single Pawn so mamedov is taking his
time he's been thinking for something
like 2 minutes minutes now but I think
he's got to go G4 and in the live
position if he plays G4 Danny it's going
to get
crazy G4 will be met by H takes and
after you take with the Knight I mean
I'm considering if I'm white just like
D4 here like I don't even need to take
another Pawn because the more open this
position becomes the more black feels
feels the consequences if it isn't the
consequences of my own actions right
that's what black is about to face the
bishop will come to C4 F7 is a Target
this bishop might even come to
A3 and I'm like this is why we de we
tell kids not to neglect their own King
safety for an allout
attack again met of a very strong player
but this whole idea of Rook G8 nepo is
is just licking his lips right now I I
think he's gonna I think he's gonna blow
Ralph off the board be look by the ways
on the board I'm loving okay but if I
could take the Devil's Advocate position
here after DT C5 which has just happened
White Center is under a lot of fire and
the obvious move here for white is to
push D5 right this is the move that your
hand wants to play probably this is the
move that Yan is gonna play but okay
after D5 black has the move Knight C
onto E5 which is a really nice
stronghold for black in the center and
let's not forget that black is ahead in
development this is a very odd thing to
say because black has flouted so many
opening rules but then again so has
white but currently black has two has
developed black has zero now I'm with
you Danny I think Ralph's position is
extremely dangerous I think he needs to
be ultra precise um but I think that he
might be able to manufacture um some
Intrigue yet in this position maybe a
move like Queen to B6 comes to mind in
order to prepare C4 and go after that F2
Pawn um Queen to Barry 6 but also Queen
to David 6 oh que okay Queen Mard B and
D thank you for doing do the David
thing I'm with you I'm with you that
he's not being blown off the board
immediately but the long-term features
favor white with the bishop pair this
King this King still has no safety and
the fact that the fact that nepo is also
up almost four minutes on the clock
already I think tells you how both the
POS players are feeling in this
position and speaking of NE speaking of
neppo and how he's feeling can we just
get a zoom in to the to the swag real
quick I don't know I don't know what
nepo woke up with today but look at that
he's brought the chess.com hoodie the
chess.com mug rocking the secret lab
chair I just had to give a shout out to
nepo in the swag
attack wow Yan pomi fresh off um his
performance in T Steel which was kind of
up and down he played all right but I'm
sure he's happy to be back home and
playing a tournament from the comfort of
his of his office E6 by Ralph that guy
is brazen this is typical ROV chest
everything is hanging I'm actually
curious Queen F6 is his idea but Jan
could push F3 this move F3 is actually
incredibly nasty because Black's Knight
on G4 doesn't have that many places to
go I mean you don't want to go back to
H6 so Yan has not developed a single
piece other than his Queen and he
actually might not develop any pieces
until the rest of until the end of the
game I mean who needs their minor pieces
anyway Danny right I I would argue that
half of them are developed where they
stand right the Bishops do a pretty good
job controlling the board when the
diagonals are open so I hear you on that
and again I'm clearly suffering from
some nepo bias I didn't mean to but I
just I look at this whole thing and I'm
just like what is going on with momenta
first of all I love it like this is the
kind of Chess you want to see but what
an awkward way to play chess just
completely neglecting the king I think
if nepo finds F three this position is
just going to continue to have fireworks
and uh Ralph mov averaging three to four
shorts eaten a tournament right now he
keeps putting the shirt over his mouth
and just keeps eating I'm like he's just
biting his shirt nervously I love it
every player has their tick and for some
players it's they're more destructive
than others you know for some it's just
fidgeting with a pawn or fidgeting with
her hair for Ralph mov it's the whole
thing he's fidgeting with his hair like
he's eating his shirt I and he's banging
the table and he might need to bang the
table because his position is on the
verge of collapse but it's Ralph this
guy lives life on the edge on and off
the board shout out to the fair play
team in the background hi Mom hi Sean I
love you call me
later there there's the there's our
there's our field division back there oh
my gosh um well I mean we can go to
another game I feel like this one has
had all the entertainment we need we got
chesc swag we got a player eatting his
fifth shirt of the event we've got fairf
play cameras and we've got fireworks on
the board but we haven't checked in on
so many other games I'm just gonna I'm
gonna flash to remind everybody um that
uh that they can go to chess.com events
this is the position currently between
Sean and
so Wesley da once again reminding
reminding everybody why he is the last
person chosen consistently not someone
anyone wants to face in a in a very very
solid position is black yeah he's just
always better this his default in with
any color against any opponent is he's
just slightly better um he's been
slightly better this entire event and
he's slightly better in this position
he's got a beautiful Bishop wow also
Gary versus lazic apparently locked in
an interesting battle as well but Sam
Sean he needs to trade carefully in this
position Bishop takes F3 is threatened
Bishop on D5 is beautiful okay this
middle game is going to go on for a
while I agree and we can go to the game
you just quickly mentioned I think giri
loic might have a little more Spice in
store because Dennis lavic was one was
chosen by hikaro Nakamura he sent hikaro
to division 2 an giri chose Dennis lazic
as the opponent everybody and Dennis
lavic is once again flexing his black I
think I think the old guard might
reconsider choosing this kid going
forward yeah I mean they're picking on
him and Dennis says you know what I'm
going to embrace this role not just
spoiler not just oh I'm going to win a
oneoff game here and there he wants to
win this this enti thing and he believes
that he can do that I mean there was a
reason this guy qualified to the CCT
finals in Toronto looks like he might be
going astray here in his last couple of
moves no question that Dennis is in the
driver seat in this position look at how
passive look at how passive Anish gir's
position is that Knight on C5 is aiming
at the long-term weakness on D3 but I
feel like Anish has more or less
stabilized the situation his position is
very ugly but I don't think Dennis has
any clear ways to make inroads and
that's why he just dropped his Queen
back to D7 just kind of regrouping for a
potential second wave of the
attack completely agree with you
although whether Dennis is winning or
not as black that that that would be a
feat that would be really impressive to
do that in back-to-back matches but I
think objectively he's doing fantastic
as black okay a couple of missteps as
you said deciding he's just going to
regroup um but even a draw not be the
worst result for the youngster uh to uh
to start off this match up again but
here comes garyi maybe maybe if this
Knight has to
move white can start to
unwind yeah Black's Advantage has just
sort of methodically evaporated move by
move I'm not sure I understand Dennis's
previous move Rook to E6 I thought the
Rook was perfectly well placed on F6 it
was pressuring the F3 pun but he
probably wants to bring it back to E8 or
E7 and and contest some of this nasty
queenside pressure that Anish giri has
been able to orchestrate with his own
Rooks and Anish maybe will try to get
his Knight out of the gates here Knight
D2 and Knight B3 is an idea Knight D2 is
on the board and the eval bar doesn't
like anything that's good it doesn't
like teddy bears it you know thinks
about hurting K flowers or or
unicorns you
know
yeah I was with you on the eval bar
train let's let's let's beat up the eval
bar we hate you evil eval bar all right
but Gary is uh Gary is trying to trade
off Black's pressure so that the queen
is no longer imprison to guarding the D3
pawn and I I wonder if Dennis should
have just traded in simplified now Gary
can slide the queen over or even
consider C5 to keep some space here this
is interesting it could start to turn
around yes but on the other hand Anish
is really abandoning his own King so
Dennis first of all should probably put
a rook on B8 just to kind of again just
to contest White's pressure on the queen
side so I would start with the move Rook
to ba that's a very lazic Type move
later on Rook B is on the board that
Knight on B3 is kind of awkward if it
moves back to D2 lazic could jump his
own Knight into C5 let's not forget the
D3 Pawn is a long-term Target the second
thing I'll point out is that wh's King
is kind of all alone so later in the
game maybe black can go for F7 F5 but if
so then that's way in the future because
right now this is not a very feasible
plan White's got that Queen on A2 that's
exing Black's king and the position
continues to heat up maybe you could
play H5 and try to shatter White's King
side that way I don't know this is a
very complex position you stole my
thunder I was going to go full Alpha
zero and suggest exactly that plan
because you highlight the king is alone
and this Pawn is on G3 right pawns can't
move backward very good I've heard so H5
H4 and and now white is uh a little
frustrated especially with this queen
able and happily sliding over on the
sixth rank if you give her a chance so
uh okay I like Dennis loic's chances
here that move maybe not super accurate
Mutual time pressure will also be
interesting in this matchup I don't know
that either of these players are
particularly known for their bullet or
Mouse skills but if we get Mutual time
scrambling then uh I guess we'll find
out whose nerves are best today at
least okay really interesting position
interesting positions all around all
around I I'm going to go back to the
game that had our fancy to start I I
know we haven't checked in the others
reminder you can go to chest.com events
if you want that's why this is exciting
we are spoiled for Choice yand pishi
currently up a pce
and White's position is still pretty
good like like we left it White's
completely winning and you called it I
mean this entire opening operation it
was interesting it was entertaining but
ultimately it backfired and maybe mov
was okay if he played with computer
Precision but right now he can take on
E3 but then white will have two pieces
for a rook and what black king is all
alone the knight from D2 is coming into
F3 this game is over y Yan is not going
to let this one slip the other thing I I
called earlier was that the time was
revealing Yan was up 4 minutes when we
left it he's still up 4 minutes now and
mov is uh down to the wire now if he
doesn't take he may lose his chance
White's going to put the Knight on D4
unpinning The Rook on
E3 uh he does it Rook H6 is nothing you
can just play Queen G3 I think we're
about to see this one be over so where
do you want to go next timan FIA yes
that game is heating up you read my mind
Danny um I'll also point out that Wesley
it continues to outplay s San but that
game hasn't changed all that much so
maybe we can go back to that one a
little bit later this game the center
has blown open and look at what's
happening now ala fua has jumped out and
has the initiative after being worse for
most of the first part of the game now
it feels like black is very much in the
driver's seat yeah okay the Queens have
been Queens have been traded pawns are
equal in terms of total material but
Black's D Pawn is passed it's also
isolated so here comes artv who enters
the chessable Masters for the first time
remember he was one of the players
preceded into the second round of
divisional placement
um and
uh and yeah
um he's down on the clock though what is
Peru's plan to guard the dwn and keep
his chances alive remember these are two
game mini matches as as uh as we've
already seen we didn't get a single arm
reging tiebreaker in the first round by
the way Don we didn't even talk about
that that's kind of funny we didn't get
a single a single match go to Armageddon
we'll see if that Trend continues wow
that's just how combative these matches
are something tells me that we will get
at least one Armageddon in this second
round of matchups but again we never
know by the way it's official Yan pishi
um our first result it's a decisive one
nepi crushes Ralph mov who will need to
win on Demand with the white pieces it
feels like this game is fizzling out D4
Knight takes D4 now Bishop takes E5 okay
also this this is a drop everything is
traded okay alza has a smidge of an
advantage because the bishop in the open
board is going to be a little bit better
than the night but vladislav artv is not
the kind of guy who typically loses
these sorts of end games Rook B6 is very
accurate and we might see Bishop D4 Rook
D4 Bishop takes G2 which is one way of
making a draw fanc your way of making a
draw but this game is going to end in
peace I'm 99% sure of that
Danny agreed and I misspoke in saying
that we had two game matches we will
have four game matches in this second
round of play we started off with two
game matches but with the preceded
players entering the fold we get a
little more at stake here with four
games to be played which means winner of
each match requires two and a half
points now not one and a half I'm with
you that I would be shocked if we don't
have at least one matchup go to
Armageddon though so from that
perspective I I still think we're going
to get we're going to get some very
closely contested chfs here um okay you
already pointed out y palom she won
against Ralph mov this one is likely to
be a draw we could check in with well
the top seed from the playin in the
Swiss jbam Jose martinz the birthday boy
of
yesterday in a in a position where all
pal remain that's the Highlight here not
a single Pawn has been
traded I but I think this is just a
locked up position but 38 seconds for
Jose that Bishop on B3 is that Bishop
trapped probably not because it's
threatening to emerge via A4 but now it
is kind of Trapped what a ridiculous
position what a ridiculous e Rook E8
traps the Knight Rook A3 TR but Rook A3
yeah Rook E8 Rook A3 Bishop C2 Rook
see1 an eye for an eye is what we're
about to see my God and Jose might
actually be better here if the Knight is
traded for the bishop and by the way he
can play Knight takes G5 and and throw
the Knight away for a pawn I would play
Knight takes G5 and then Rook A3 he does
it and as locked up as the position is
it's not actually a dead draw maybe
black can set up a fortress with I don't
know bishop d8 and B6 but I'm actually
not totally sure how to make that happen
Jose also has his other Knight Danny
that will eventually emerge from F3 and
it can circle around to D5 this is
really really nasty for black all of a
sudden totally agreed uh what a weird
position this was and be I was going to
say will we get something desperate
black knows black knows he doesn't want
to go for something super closed so he's
trying to force force complications by
the way that's an incredible point out
that if if Rook takes B3 B4 and The Rook
is trapped on B3 dude B5 is an
incredible move if you play a takes B5
black plays A4 you have to go for this
line and now the Rook is arrested you
might have to play D4 at some point to
extricate The Rook I think it's just a
draw I think this was the way the only
way for black to secure a draw cleanly
because now it's literally just a mutual
Fortress there's no way forward and this
is just a draw I would ignore the point
three evaluation that's just the
computer being stupid completely agree
and uh computer speaking of computer
being stupid I feel like we missed the
mark and not calling B5 a brilliant move
what an
absolutely what an absolutely stunning
move B5 anything else where you give up
this bishop white has to slow potential
to grind yeah it's iffy and we by the
way we still have one game going but
this this was an incredible save there
at the End by samil B5 in time pressure
he makes the draw with the black pieces
a great result in the first game but
again it's a four- game match this is a
marathon not a Sprint it looks like
Wesley so has defeated Sam San with
black in the first game we we had games
going but but now I think they're all in
the books Wesley so beat seian fuia and
artmia draw nepo already beat mov as we
know giri and lavic have ended the first
game of their match peacefully and josam
and sill t t yakin as we can see draw so
once again it feels like it's over right
right when it starts D yeah these games
they're so fastpaced 10 plus two is a
lovely time control it's a great balance
because you get the time scrambles you
get the fast-paced action but you
actually have enough time to play a
really high quality game which I think
yand pomi and Wesley so demonstrated
Wesley's game we didn't necessarily do
it justice but it was a great positional
effort Yan pishi ier and I punishing
Ralph mto's speculative opening play and
off to a great start in their mini match
completely agreed uh I I think mov might
be a dream opponent for yand pishi as
long as Yan is is on form because mov
doesn't know anything but one speed
which is insanity speed insanity is what
Ralph mov loves to do and if nepo is on
form he's just going to say come at me
big fella because a player of Neo's
class knows how to win against wild
openings like that that was that was a
ton of fun uh all right other than nepo
getting the dub as you pointed out
Wesley so versus Sam sevian was not a
match that we gave a ton of time to but
Wesley so is the last person chosen in
this format for a reason and he gets the
job done winning with black for the
second match in a row yeah he seems to
have adopted the kind of boa constrictor
mode today that makes him so scary I
mean this is the kind of Wesley so that
won the cgc in Toronto when Wesley gets
that confidence and he starts winning
game after game with both colors you
know he's essentially Unstoppable so Sam
seian he needs to stem the bleeding now
let's remember very important Danny this
is a four-game match so if you've lost
the first game that doesn't mean that
you need to burn all of your Bridges
particularly with the black pieces Sam
seian should play it safe he should try
to be solid with black now pounce on any
opportunities if you get them but don't
go crazy trying to win game two and dig
yourself into a two Z hole from which
it's virtually impossible to emerge with
against someone like Wesley
completely agree for those who lost this
this next round is a bit of a stop the
bleeding round don't go down 20 we are
now in 4 game matches here on the second
day of the divisional placement round we
had the play in Swiss we now have match
play tomorrow players like Magnus
Carlson MBL and fedos have joined the
fold the format is one that everyone has
talked a lot about which is why we
continue to do everything we
can
huh well that didn't work out well about
as about as complicated to figure out
our audio issues here as the format
itself but da we're back and we're
getting ready for the next round of play
uh all right so you talked about the
mindset of the losers uh meaning
respectively Ralph mov as well as Sam
Sevan everyone else is kind of just
getting started right shaking off the uh
the rust for those who just entered the
play shaking off the Jitters if you're
someone like vladislav artmia Yan pish
I mean we talk about it it's a balance
you're more well rested so you come in
with a clear head on the other hand you
didn't have the benefit of yesterday's
tournament so you're maybe not quite as
warmed up you're not quite as tactically
sharp which is I think why we saw
vladislav artf kind of managing the risk
playing a somewhat quieter less risky
game but still a great result for oi
Resa fua holding with the black pieces
and I'm really curious what Ali RZA will
be able to do against the Ultra solid
artmia with the white pieces it's going
to be a really interesting second
game yeah I agreed artm is a guy who
maybe isn't as quickly known as guys
like Anish giri y pishi entering the
fold even Sam seian I guess if you're uh
someone who's been following the young
American Career for a long time but timv
is a is an absolute monster an absolute
Beast especially in Rapid and online
play We we've been following him for
more than a decade and uh and yeah he's
not someone who is who is not capable of
beating fua so yeah we are going to dive
in okay we've uh we've got all the
choices we want as usual Yan pesi Ralph
mov I've got that one pulled up we can
also switch over to
sale tah hakin
versus josam maybe we'll start
there okay then we have a fairly
standard BOGO Indian
structure that's the classic pawns on B6
A5 and B4 you essentially only get that
out of one opening you get that out of
the BOGO Indian and yeah Jose is just it
really cannot be emphasized enough how
well prepared he is with both colors
against D4 and E4 it it gives him such a
big boost in most Blitz tournaments and
most rapid tournaments he's usually up a
minute at least out of the opening and
this is no exception
he's up a minute in a comfortable spot
as black uh the you say BOGO Indian and
I'm looking at the Knight on A6 but even
as someone who plays in nimzo and has to
be aware of these different BOGO and
queens Indian transpositions I'm
actually struggling to figure out the
move order so I'm just going to quickly
roll through it in my head selfish chess
player educating himself here just want
to see how we got here okay Knight F3
and then the bishop before before check
was C5 line okay I'm all cut up now
everybody thanks for being patient I
feel better
my pleasure your wish is my command and
queen out to E2 okay I think
traditionally white is maybe a tiny bit
better the computer usually likes
White's space advantage on the other
hand black has very very nice central
control and black is a very clearly
defined plan of pushing E5 and staking
his claim in the center and if after E5
white pushes D5 black gets this monster
C5 Square the Knight on A6 is easy to
cast away as a bad piece but it's
actually not a bad piece at all it's
protecting the B4 pawn and it's ready to
jump into the action if the C5 Square
opens
up yeah it's a fantastic point it's also
out of the way of the bishop on B7 so
basic principles say a knight on the rim
is grim right or dim or chances are slim
I honestly don't know as long as it
Rhymes the Knight over here is usually
not a great piece but in terms of the
overall functionality of the position
it's actually pretty good for black you
stay out of the way of the bishop you
actually stay out of the way of the C
file you're not fighting the other
Knight for squares and you're protecting
B4 so a very comfy and cozy position for
josam here comfy and cozy is a good way
to put it shall we uh keep moving around
the horn I think Jose has basically
stabilized out of the opening we have
this Wesley versus seian game that I see
you have your eyes on um okay this is
just started so this is another Nimo
Indian and a very
n Indian I was going to say it's the
classical Nimo we see played a lot and
there are a lot of variations in this
particular Nimo that can go to a force
draw okay B6 is an option there for
black one that one that sometimes brings
up the idea of this diagonal being under
Fire but okay not in this particular
move order because the C7 Palm was
hanging
uh Wesley takes a pause here I'm now out
of my depth as the pauses in my voice
are revealing
da out my on move too I mean once G6 was
not played and E6 was played all right
that's basically all I know of course I
play the Nimo Indian as my backup
opening but I don't know much about it
all I know is that Sam seian is
preparing E5 and the big question is can
you get away with E5 in this position
the obvious answer is no because white
can respond with D5 but there's a lot of
tactics in that position maybe black and
push E4 and this is exactly what you
want if you're Sam and a sharp Tactical
right out of the opening and E5 is on
the board he does it5 can be met with E4
everything's Under Fire the B2 Pawn the
Knight on F3 the Knight on C6 the queen
can take E4 this is an absolutely crazy
position who's gonna who's gonna be more
deeply prepared between the two I don't
know but I am gonna say something da as
fun as these classical nimos look I'll
be the cynical one in the room for a
second I feel like they are often very
very forcing draws and both players just
have it prepared to the end there's it's
totally true I mean first of all in this
position Bishop to F5 uh is I think an
even more ambitious attempt although we
might see Queen takes B2 you're
absolutely right Danny a lot of these
just end in Perpetual checks like Queen
takes B2 the computer is giving the line
like Rook D1 Queen C3 check Rook D2
Queen C1 check and chess will always
find a way to fizzle out into a draw no
matter how exciting it
looks yeah well I mean okay now you're
really being cynical um but do we even
know objectively that chess is a force
draw we always say that but even the
computers and neural Nets don't always
play chess to a draw I might be cynical
but I think we're getting this exact
Perpetual check and people looking at
this might be like why is Sam Sean going
for a forcing draw again this is a four
game match a draw with the black pieces
is fine I mean you do want the white
pieces against Wesley so that is your
best chance to fight back and score a
victory even though you did lose with
white in game one can Sam San keep keep
fighting here I don't think so I think
we're going to get a Perpetual check and
a very quick draw yeah and and we called
it before this second set of games
started we said that if you're a player
who lost the first the first game it's
kind of a stop the- bleeding mentality
as exciting as it would be to win on
command I also don't judge chevan for
this quick draw given that he doesn't
want it to get away from him against a
player like Wesley so so unfortunately
we both foreshadowed what was the truth
which is that classical nimos are not
the Berlin but they are lines that white
can often safely choose and have some
deep prep that forces a draw from
Wesley's perspective he protects his one
game lead well said and here we have a r
Lopez in fua versus artmia just a kind
of extremely standard run-ofthe-mill R
Lopez position which also can arise out
of an Italian I made this point earlier
in um to us steel commentary we have
this kind of weird
convergence because when people play the
ru Lopez now they often play these
Sidelines with D3 and these Sidelines
with D3 often transition back into
positions that you can get out of an
Italian so this is a fairly non-
theoretical battle and it's a typical
artmia type position he likes these long
drawn out maneuvering battles he's
really really good in
them he's really good at them often he's
the faster player right now fuja doing a
very good job maintaining a little bit
of an advantage on the clock so uh so
we'll see if that pays off but you're
right now that we've checked in with
this one and we see a little bit of a
preview in terms of what the evaluation
is in our other matchups SEL Tura hakin
teeny Edge against Jose Martinez mamedov
and nepo 5050 lavic doing okay over
there against giri let's let's actually
go over to that game reminder everybody
if you missed it the biggest story of
the day Dennis lvic sending hikaro
Nakamura home in shocking fashion here
he has a small Edge against Anish Kiri
in our second set of matches yeah and if
you're Dennis loc you know what should
your strategy be against Anish giri to
try to score a second massive upset I
think you want to drag this you want to
make three draws and you want everything
to be decided in one game and this is
the classic piece of advice that's given
to sports teams
if you're the underdog you want to
shorten the game if you're the underdog
in a chess match you want to shorten the
match so maybe make three safe draws and
in one particular game absolutely
anything can happen so I think Dennis
lavic doing the right thing by being
Ultra solid in these first two games
maybe he had some winning chances in the
last game but you can't really fault him
for wanting to play it safe with the
black pieces and here again I think
we're going to get a bunch of Trades
looks like the of the minor pieces Danny
are very likely to disappear from the
board and then we're going to get some
sort of drawn
endgame agreed although as I thought
through your strategy completely agree
with the sports analogy if you are the
underdog you want to shorten the game
let it all come down to 2 minutes in the
fourth quarter right your best chance
exactly but also the other argument is
that with every game Anish giri plays
his bed head looks better right now he's
clearly attired a niche playing in his
first matches of the 2024 Champions
chess tour Anish but with every single
move Anish giri is the stronger player
and likely should be finding his form I
think Anish might have just heard me so
he fixes his hair and quickly quickly
Ducks under the camera to hide in shame
from his bed
head yeah I mean it is pretty late over
there in Europe but no judgment I'm the
last person to judge someone for taking
a late afternoon nap um but yeah I mean
this position that he's currently has on
the board I mean I would prefer white I
really like
the the Knight on G4 and how it's
pressuring the bishop on F6 you can't
just play Knight takes C3 because white
will take on F6 first and then recapture
on C3 and black will have some problems
with his kingside Pawn structure maybe
you can do that maybe that is the
fastest path to a draw but you see Queen
C6 by niri okay we are getting a bunch
of Trades here Knight takes D5 Queen
takes D5 and actually that particular
end game maybe is a little bit
preferable for black but I don't think
Dennis will have any trouble holding
this with six minutes on his clock yeah
we're going to see a draw in this game
yeah likely likely no fireworks coming
so we are going to quickly switch to one
of the other matchups speaking of
fireworks the one that gave us the most
the most of them was uh nepo versus mov
in the first game if you missed it it
was it was quite the Thriller this one
much more tame but also pretty comfy for
the uh the former World Championship
Challenger that being Yan
pomi uh not not not a bad position here
as black not a lot going
on yeah I mean this is not what Ralph
mov wanted out of a Vienna which is what
he played by the way he played E4 E5 and
then Knight to C3 clearly trying to
avoid Yan's preparation in the Petrov
which has just been his main weapon in
the last couple of years you would never
think Yan pishi would become a Petrov
expert but that's exactly what's
happened and if anything I think black
is slightly better in this end game I
mean B4 carve out the D4 Square for your
knight Rook to A8 excellent move by Yan
getting control of the only open file uh
infiltrate to A2 with your Rook okay
Ralph is trying to make something happen
on the king side but look at the way
that Jan has set up his pawns he's
controlling the G5 Square so he is
immobilizing White's pawns on the king
side and on the queen side black is
making
moves The Rook will come to the second
rank as you said this Rook this Rook on
e4 looks cute at first right but if he
doesn't he doesn't fulfill some sort of
aggressive destiny that Rook could be
super awkwardly placed we see that
nebo's Rooks communicating well on the
queen side White's Rooks feel a little
bit confused as to what should happen
next in fact on that note the right way
to maybe justify their position is to
blow open the center and here comes
D4 he's doing what he has to do uh to
muddy the waters the problem is that D4
does not really carry much of a threat I
mean does he want to play D takes C5
maybe but it's not such a scary Prospect
for Yan so maybe Jan can just continue
with his queenside program and go Rook
A2 he could consider the more explosive
move B4 but okay this is a big decision
here for Yan and that is why he's taking
a little bit more time Rook to A4 is
another move that you can consider if
you are worried about D Tak C5 and guess
what Rook A4 is on the board right on Q
look at da little guess the move action
um by the way anyone following can
actually play Guess the move if you're
into that kind of thing it's a fun
little game we often don't talk a lot
about um shout out to Dragon B70 guess
the move Legend on chess.com um all
right Rook A4 pins the D4 Pawn maybe
even makes B4 more of a
threat wow yeah Knight F5 kind of a
weird position Knight F5 has a second
Purpose By the way defends The Rook so
that D takes E5 or D5 are both a threat
great call and looks like okay Yan can
drop his Bishop back to f8 again if he
wants to sort of keep the status quo but
H5 I was going to point this move out
just hitting where it hurts look at how
Yan is using both sides of the board
Rook to A4 on the queen side H5 on the
opposite end of the board and if Ralph
plays the move F3 he continues to kind
of weaken his second Rank and then move
Rook to A2 would be a lot scarier
because the prospect of Rook take C2
would cause white to have to double back
and bring the Knight back to E3 and you
don't want to do any of
that I agree and honestly these types of
positions are just right up neppo allei
especially in Rapid and and okay we look
like looks like mov is trying to force
the issue Knight G3 made sure that that
we were going to get this capture but I
still I like Neo's chances I also like
his clock management the distance
between the two timers is only getting
greater and uh it's a little early to
say that that that yon would win his
second game in a row but it is trending
a positive direction for nepo it most
certainly is I like how Ral mov is is
Prosecuting the defensive task he's
trying to create counterplay against
that G7 Pawn that's why he played a dve
trying to fix that pawn on G7 and
preparing to jump back into F5 when when
the moment is right but there's no
question Jan is in the driver seat here
he's got that two-minute time Advantage
again Yan seems to be in very good form
it's too early to tell we don't have a
lot to go off of but I like what Jan is
showing the kind of Chess and the kind
of game control that that Yan is showing
so far in this mini match I completely
agree and he seems poised for Success
he's focused wearing that chess.com
hoodie it looks good on him I'm not
going to lie I don't I think we sent him
that hoodie a while ago in a gift
package so it's nice to see that that
swag didn't go to waste great all right
do you want a hoodie too is that what
you're saying you want me to send you
one I I would never ask no no no no I
mean not that I would complain I I
definitely it would it would enter my
regular rot wardrobe rotation I actually
really like hoodies big fan hoodies are
hoodies are great all right I always
confus the sweatshirt and sweater
terminology my wife yells at me about it
so I just go with hoodie um but all
right we've got some other games to
check in with Vladimir sorry vladislav
artv and Oli Resa fua they drew their
first game fuia with a teeny edge here
we also haven't checked in at all with
the second game between sell
tah this one's spicy josam oh there's a
is that a are you just happy to see me
look at I'm I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
put my pony on it I vote you definitely
put a pony on F3 now he's kind of
keeping this move in his pocket right
now is Jose and I think he's trying to
combine his kingside play with long-term
pressure against white C4 Pawn so we
might see him actually doubling Rooks on
the C file and trying to create another
source of pressure by the way Rook bc8
the benefit of that move is that it does
threaten maybe B5 in some situations
first he puts his Pony on F3 I mean who
could resist who could resist a check on
F3 maybe G5 is another move to consider
to try to restrict White's Knight now of
course Danny White's Knight could drop
back to E1 and trade the knights off so
I don't think that that Tera Hawkin is
in huge trouble here but I think he
needs to tread very very carefully to
keep the
balance yeah Robert hes loses his mind
anytime a pawn is three squares away
dominating a knight right Robert hes and
Angel gets his wings every time we see
that Affair but I I agree with you G5
might be a little rush because Knight E1
you've actually taken away the Escape
square of your own pony so perhaps now
we see your move Rook B to C8 and I like
what you said okay Queen F5 I'd lik to
work be to C8 because I thought it would
threaten Queen E6 which would be some
sort of double attack but instead is
just being he's being a little more
direct just going after H3 which maybe
there's just a forcing problem here now
he plays Rook C8 and is G5 a stronger
threat well also we should keep in mind
the knight from F4 can jump into D5 and
threaten a family Fork on E7 you don't
get to Fork all four of the most
important pieces often of course Jose
would prevent that fork in one of many
ways I mean King f8 he could shift one
of his his Rook from C8 to E8 so we see
King G2 by svelter sah hakin and I like
the trend of the game um for white he's
fixed the immediate problems with his
King safety the Knight on F3 yes it
looks very pretty but its counterpart on
F4 might actually be the stronger piece
with the stronger potential of migrating
over to D5 and also potentially
attacking the B6 Pawn by shifting one of
the Rooks to the B file later in the
game that's that's a really fair point
you didn't mention one idea if the
Knight goes to D5 we should always
consider an idea of Queen takes followed
by capturing here not that it's not that
it's something you should do
unnecessarily but when you have a rook
and Knight working together with a
mating net around the king let's just
let's just keep an eye on that that type
of tactic uh but you're right I mean we
talked a lot about the pressure for
josam a little bias but the more you
look at the position weakness weakness
weakness this Knight might find the D5
Square so you have to be careful if
you're black yeah it's absolutely
anybody's game I like Jose from the
clock perspective he's up a minute on
the clock he's got probably more meat on
the bone when it comes to kingside
attacking chances but it's anybody's
game I was also wondering if we could
quickly check back into the LZ of giri
game because I'm surprised that it still
hasn't ended yet okay never mind it is
about to end and we will get I I was
keeping an eye on it which is why I
didn't go to it but you you forc my hand
we'll just let everybody know that we're
likely to get our our second peaceful
result in this match it's okay no it was
great uh so we checked in with that one
again there also hasn't been well
there's been some changes in
this it's like an opening but they
players already have like a minute 20
for Vlad and 2 minutes 20 for OA and the
center is opening up look at the tactics
from art Knight takes D5 yeah wow Bishop
takes D5 Rook takes
C1 the bishop is hitting the Knight here
the Rooks will be traded and it
wait stutter because I don't know what's
gonna happen you actually you actually
cannot play Bishop takes D5 because the
irony is that white actually loses a
piece at the end of the line yep no and
let's show it which is why I started
stuttering instead of recommending a
line because Bishop takes D5 is one of
those moves that backfires we trade you
take and we gain a Tempo on the queen
before gobbling up that Pony who put
itself on the rim of the board so that's
exactly why we have fuia thinking what
other moves are possible does he just to
put the Knight on F5 yeah okay this is
probably oh he's played it there we go
and Knight takes E3 we are we're getting
action here
as you said this is kind of an opening
in a bullet game I mean move 23 they're
basically playing bullet chest now I
love artmus position his Bishop on B7
right don't sleep on that Bishop he's
got this idea of swinging his Rook from
C6 over to G6 and his Queen from d8 can
come into the action with Queen to G5 if
oi Resa takes on E7 that Queen can go
one of a million different directions
Danny as you're pointing out now alza is
now down on the clock he's in some
trouble here yes this is what's
happening rookie G okay Queen G5 is also
really irritating because it's a skewer
to the Rooks so you can't meet Queen G5
with the obvious Rook
G3 uh oh Queen G5 is a very nasty move
Queen G5 that actually is really
irritating because you try to okay I got
to show it we're back to the analysis
board if you play a natural move with
the Rook I I want to just sacrifice the
queen on G2 but I can't so instead I'll
sacrifice the rook and threaten check
here and note that something like Rook
G3 doesn't work because of Queen to D2
oh that's so important and that is why
in the current game position I think
Queen G5 has been played Oli Resa finds
the correct move Rook F1 because here
after Rook takes C4 Rook G3 in the line
that you just showed you can't move the
queen away with Tempo what presence of
mind to spot this in two seconds as ala
fua
now the sacrifice on G2 and Rook G6
check is probably a dead end because
white can always cover the Discover
check with his Bishop from D5 um it's
very tempting but you have to avoid
these speculative options yeah Rook G2
it kind of gives you a rush to play all
of these moves but then you resign after
Bishop D5 okay so he's made a move he's
got 25 seconds on the clock and he's
played Rook to G6 threatening
checkmate Okay g it seems that despite
the fireworks we might be seeing a a
pair of Rooks followed by a pair of
Bishops and ultimately heading toward a
little bit of a tame end game although
even that we shouldn't dismiss the
potential for a decisive result I like
this move Bishop to D5 first he's kind
of saying look if you take yeah those
pawns are doubled but my king will have
a perfectly safe little cocoon to hide
itself in and eventually become a
beautiful butterfly great point and the
A5 Pawn is a long-term weakness
in the event of the trade which has just
happened seconds now foris art suddenly
he the one who has to keep his position
together how is he going to defend the
A5 pawn and now the E5 Pawn is also
hanging maybe Queen to D4 can be tried
but now takes takes and Rook out five
still yeah still some defensive effort
required I think it is a draw but let's
see if Lattis love Artu has what it
takes he's not warmed up this could
backfire and the nepo game ends in a
draw by the way yeah Nebo has ended in a
draw Anish gir lavic has ended in a draw
if you're just tuning in we already had
a very early draw between Wesley so and
Sam Sean we will update you about each
of those matches respectively in a
minute but okay
fua first to win a pawn he's going into
a rook ending with an extra peska likely
should be a draw with best play but timv
with only five seconds yeah and I mean
this is not the worst version to have if
you're oi Resa fuja he's going to be
playing G4 one second for vladislav and
H5 very important move very
nice oh the presence of mind to throw
this move in with 1 second on the clock
G4 played anyway but every Pawn trade is
helping black yeah this should be a
pretty makeable
draw Pawn trade helps the defender we're
going to get a trade of the D for the B
Pawn this single outside a pawn likely
not enough and after Rook to
B4 simplification that we called for
this Rook is ideally placed behind the
pass pawn and also cutting off the Kings
aggressive action so so good stuff good
defense from ourmia we've seen this
before Rook G4 can be tried F6
H4 but black steps away one second oh my
God barely got that move up King H7 and
okay this is a two-on one Danny Ali res
is going to torture him I actually don't
know why artv didn't play F6 there and
defend the pawn but this is still very
drawable this is pretty easy you just
shuffle your pieces back and forth just
don't blunder your Rook do not blunder
your Rook do not preo do not pass go and
collect $200 appreciate the pro tip
don't blunder The Rook got it it that's
all you have to
do oh and samuil tah Hawkin blundered a
queen Fork he blundered his Queen and
he's going to
lose oh my gosh he is he has lost we I I
forgot that matchup was still going I
guess we're going to let this well okay
we'll go see what the final moments of
that one were in just a second we're not
going to leave the only game in progress
uh but yeah SEL tah hawen blunders his
queen against josam in one move
ouch that's just what Jose does to I
mean the guy is in such good form he
puts a lot of pressure on the board on
the clock samvel with a big blow will
cover that game momentarily but oi Resa
he's still trying and this is a big
moment where do you go with the King if
you're black H5 can be tried F5 maybe
it's still a draw but it's getting a
little
dicey what do you do now
these yeah this is gonna get weird King
G2 Rook F4 King
G3 Rook F1 still a draw King
G7 yeah holding
everything still they make it look easy
with no time on the clock dude imagine
if you're sitting there on your vladis
Lavia playing this against fua I like
you said Danny they make it look so easy
but trust me it's it's not it's actually
really hard to hold these positions Al
Reza knows every little trick to make
you work for
it yeah and uh the presence of Mind by
artum to know exactly when to bring the
Rook behind the pawns only after White
had played H5 this is really Stellar
technique not that anyone here is
probably here for this level of Rook
ending education but if you are check
out the defense by artm in this one
later this was really accurate stuff and
the eval bar reveals it there's just
been no blunders just perfect chest from
black we might get a three-time
repetition here actually because this
type of position has already been
reached Rook G1 Rook F1 and Black's Rook
basically has just enough squares along
the f file you have Rook F4 and if the
white king moves to G3 you check the
king from G1 and go back to F4 or F1
okay Rook takes F6 and G5 is futile
because white is left with an H Pawn it
is a cool trick to be aware of but it
doesn't work in this type of position
okay that's it I think we're going to
get a draw momentarily here yeah the
moment the King goes to G3 The Rook goes
back to F1 I think we already saw that
position twice I think fuan knows that
which is why he played this awkward Rook
F7 move but still there's uh not a lot
going to happen here King H6 back I mean
he's just going to keep his Rook on F3
as long as
possible yeah this is this is easy Rook
up one and a draw by repti like that
okay we quickly go over to the somville
tah Hocking game just to see that it was
it was
equal it was equal no we're doing our
our own little game review hit the game
review button everybody and you might
see that you lost just because of one
move Queen to F3 well was down upon at
this point it was already kind of bad
but actually Jose was the one Jose was
the one down to
5 Seconds to S 12 but what a blunder I
mean this is a very drawable position
Danny he should have held this with
proper defense but it's fair Jos Bam's
up a pawn there's a threat of Queen G3
we should give credit where credits do
yes it was a blunder but obviously the
pressure brought by Jose Martinez is
something he did a lot yesterday which
is why he was our top finisher in the
play in Swiss the pressure here once
again pays off he gets his first dub in
his match and uh and takes that one and
a half to half lead so all right let's
bring up the scoreboard and show
everybody where we sit the action is
fast it is furious we love you been
diesel I think we do we'll talk about
that later da your
thoughts what an around I mean this is a
very fascinating 4 game mini match
there's a lot of match strategy involved
we saw Sam seban not mining a draw I
think that's good that's what you have
to do but he will have to strike with
the white pieces Yan pomi he takes care
of business puts him puts himself One
Step close closer to taking his match
and gir veric two draws Danny that is
going to be a fascinating final two
games Dennis what a Cinderella run and
it continues he's doing great against
anishi thus far yeah Dennis lavic sent
hiar Nakamura home for those just
joining and if DA's strategy is the
correct one then Dennis lvic is on track
he says look if you're the underdog keep
it close let it all come down to one
game Dennis lvic is trying to drag Anish
giri deep into the dark woods and Hope
it comes down to a coin flip so all
right that one's locked up you already
gave us a quick rundown there I think
Wesley so of course as you said with a
with a lead over Sam Sean this might be
Sam Sean's Last Chance going into this
next game where he has the white pieces
but okay before we continue our action
here discovering who will get their
division one hopes uh who will keep
their division one hopes alive we're
joined once again by Tanya SJ Tanya has
been keeping an eye on all the other
action that we can't possibly follow in
divisions two and three Tanya how are
you and what do you got for us I'm all
over the place because while I'm keeping
my eye out on all the other divisions I
can't keep my eyes off what's happening
in division one drama that was great
technique by artf danis lazic doing
amazing things holding Anish G to two
draws uh we saw that Rook Pawn ending at
the end with our Tamia so I thought I'll
bring up the antidote to that and show a
real classic attacking match that we had
in division three I'm going to rewind go
back in time because Danny some games
are just so beautiful that they're
Timeless and this is from the match
Daniel dubov versus uh mean Le five
decisive games all won by white and this
is from game two uh Daniel dubo with the
white pieces he lost game one so he's
got to make his comeback in this and it
started slow in the opening we had a fan
opening I'm going to go through the
opening really quick uh and get to the
fun stuff so we saw black take control
of the center early on and uh dubov
pushes on the queen side if given a free
hand he's going to go marching down the
board Target the base of the pawn chain
he stopped immediately with the move A5
and the pieces continue to come out as
black finishes development tuov strikes
in the center challenges blacks Advanced
Pawns in the center this is all pretty
standard after the trades we see the
bishop come out the bishop goes back
some more trades to follow and so far so
good both players um playing um playing
good chess taking out pieces and this is
when things start to get spicy not
Sriracha level just yet Dan but we are
getting there black decides to make the
move E4 opening up the center opening up
the queen you can take this Pawn with
either the pawn or The Rook black will
recapture the pawn on B2 destroy White's
Pawn structure for Daniel dubov it's not
enough that you can capture with two
pieces he decides he wants another piece
there which is the Knight the Knight
Knight falls back to D2 dubov has never
cared about the pawns he wants active
pieces he wants that Knight on e4 black
snaps up the pawn on D3 the Knight jumps
in attacks the queen tuov has given up
two pawns picks up one of them in return
for the pawn sacrifice look at that
peace activity meanwhile black still
lacking development jumps in with the
Knight a really nice move follows up
Queen to D6 not giving black the time to
take out the bishop to E6 excuse my
arrows but if you do play Bishop to E6
white will Target the queen and there's
no way that the queen can remain
connected to the Knight on E5 so Dua
really making sure that mle cannot
develop the bishop and the queen side
pieces the queen is hit comes back once
again it's all about Tempo when you're
on the attack and the initiative a queen
trade Daniel Duba knows nothing about
Queen trades he's going for the king the
queen slides into H5 also notice how
most of black pieces are on the queen
side so black sking is feeling a little
bit in the danger zone things start to
get exciting really really soon but the
Precision by dubov H the way he executed
the attack from this moment on is super
instructive he first hits the queen on
B4 making it go to a square that's not
ideal you really want to fall back on E7
get it closer to your own King but if
you do that you fall in the line of the
White's Rook moves like Knight D2 maybe
there's something better but I think the
Knight just comes back and you've got
attack Knight D2 is amazing Tanya Knight
D2 wow that wins a night it would win
the night on the spot instead of walking
into that he goes back to B6 and now
dubab is setting up his final blow with
starting with a retreating move with the
bishop to F1 because this knight from C4
is the one piece that can get fastest to
the king's defense from
E5 he first attacks it black defends it
dubov trades it and Dan you're going to
love what happened next white just
decides to give up pieces to get to
Black's King in true Daniel dubar style
and Bo Knight to F6 check forcing the
black Pawn on G7 to grab the Knight Dam
take my knight give me your king jumps
up with a rook to E4 do you even Rook
lift dbob apparently does we've seen all
those videos of him working out and
don't forget that move Bishop to F1
which got rid of that Knight to E5 so
there is no more defense here The Rook
comes into the attack the Bish B attacks
The Rook gives a check if you move the
king Rook H4 wins the game on the spot
the bishop falls back tuob doesn't care
picks up the pawn the rook and the queen
are lining up the mate is incoming sure
take my Rook give me your double
exclamation mark Daniel dubov is going
all out for black king which cannot be
defended gives a check the final few
moves the final desperate attempts it
doesn't matter there's a mate in one
which needs to be defended the queen
defends it The Rook comes back final
check and after F3 there's nothing to be
done sure you can go Queen A2 King H3
would follow the king would eventually
hide and you cannot stop the mate on the
H file Duba sacrifices a knight
sacrifices a rook and wins a game in
classic Duba style went on to win the
match and eliminated mean
Le that's a Master Class by dubba Master
Class by you that was fascinating I feel
like I feel like dubab plays the moves
that I dream about and he somehow makes
them work I can never make it
work yeah if I would give up the Knight
and a rook I'd probably just lose after
two M even if I thought it was a great
attack but he just started with such
style and finished it off his execution
in this game was so on point and Daniel
uh I know that you really enjoy these
kind of attack Knight F6 would be a
bullet move for you as well yeah except
it would be unsound but in Dub's case it
is perfectly sound great explanation
Tanya that was riveting and Daniel dubov
I mean no matter what division he's in
he's just everyone's favorite player
he's so fun to watch and we should
remind everybody no matter what division
they're in now you win division three
you're guaranteed at least division two
you win division two you get automatic
placement division one so these games
are not just for the educational and
awesome analysis by Tanya so all right
stick with us of course we have plenty
of Chess ahead and as we throw to a
break we know that a lot of our viewers
are watching because they want to get
better they want to become Chess Masters
but they might find that it's harder to
become a chess master than they first
thought when they started falling in
love with the game of Kings but maybe
it's your setup so uh check check out
the info we've got for you at the
[Music]
break
this is John John loves to study
chess this is David David loves to study
chess as well but
efficiently John spends more time
setting up the board and figuring out
what's on the page of his book then he
gets to
study David likes to take it easy and
use his time
wisely
David has finished his exercise for
today John should try the
[Music]
same
welcome to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic ch spectacle is
none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially
exciting be sure to watch all the games
on the live stream at chess.com and on
our
style chess goat challenge at the
luxurious weisson House Resort
experience the thrill and fascination of
Chess in a completely new
light the year-long Champions chess tour
consists of four main online events and
one live final each event will begin
with a play in tournament 69 players
from the playin 69 really nice you had
to choose that number Michael will be
joined on the second day by the four
qualifiers from the previous Tour event
Michael does that even work how do we
have 73 players competing in knockout
chess all right okay in each event
players also ACR points for the season
long leader board the final standings
will decide who joins so we have a Swiss
match play double elimination knockout
and a leaderboard being being tracked
throughout to ultimately
determine players for the live final
that's right okay that's honestly if
you're a little confused that's okay but
the math checks out you can trust us the
works okay watch all the action as the
best chess players in the world compete
to be crowned it's not 73 players in
divisional play it's only 56 players in
division play it's 73 in division
placement coming out of the Swiss plus
the four people division plays is 8 plus
16 plus 32 yeah I'm just we got to
restart the video the next CCT
Champion Jesus what are we doing
[Music]
here
[Applause]
love that
video I love that video I love Meetup
use Meetup find other local chess
players in your area we love them
appreciate their sponsorship and support
we continue on it's time for the third
round da in the 2024 Champions chess
tour inaugural event that is the
chessable Masters that is where you are
if you are somehow lost on the internet
da we could jump in and go a lot of
different places to kick things off I'm
gonna I'm going to choose our adventure
real quick and just go to a nich giri
Dennis
laic doing that I really love this match
I really really like this match I want
to see how far Dennis laic goes and this
is a pivotal game Danny because if
you're in E giri you don't want to rely
on defeating Dennis lzc with the black
pieces in the last game and you
certainly don't want this to get into
Armageddon because we know that
absolutely anything can happen you want
to inrease the chances that something
crazy happens so for an giri who plays
the same opening that we played in the
last round of T Steel to defeat vidit
but Dennis lazic chooses a slightly
different counter setup we have a
completely symmetrical collie system
also known as the zukertort uh setup at
least the way it was taught to me yeah
hey that's the thing about chess
openings is there's lots of different
names you know who claimed it first I
guess but we can see based on our eval
bar right as I say it opening Theory
ends we were still following roads that
have been traveled many times before oh
yeah I would argue even here even if the
opening book no longer has enough depth
to not just switch to a traditional
engine eval this is a position we've
seen a lot of times out of these
structures white puts the Knight on E5
you're kind of you're kind of hoping for
an exchange and then maybe a quick
assault of the king side whether it's F
or Knight enters you're trying to get
some kind of attack going here the
collie system is like the less cool more
old school younger brother of the London
system now it's like everybody's
ordering off Amazon but there was a time
when Kmart uh was like the leader in the
field there was a time when Sears uh
sent out a catalog and that's how you
got what you wanted so the collie system
had its moment in the sun it's gotten
less popular but it's still a very good
opening it's a very solid opening it's a
good way to avoid the by now well troden
Paths of the London system but I also
like the way the Dennis Lac is
responding to it he's basically copying
all of anisha's moves and anisha's moves
are usually pretty good so they deserve
to be
copied whoever had da makes a comparison
from the Ki zukor to Kmart on their
bingo you win I obviously had to turn
and type that up can we clip and ship
that moment when was the last time we
compared any opening to
Kmart old enough to pretend that you
remember Kmart you know I remember
getting excited when my mom took me to
Kmart all right there is still a Kmart
actually that's open I think the only
Kmart that's still open is in North
Carolina but I'm
actually um not totally
sure no permanently closed the Kmart and
charlott's permanently I was going to
say it's almost like the Vintage
Blockbuster the guy who owns the only
Blockbuster left in the world right I
think that's in Bend Oregon shout out
shout out to you you know this bu this
buds for you um but uh yeah this is this
is crazy um we have an opening that now
white gets a little bit little bit more
than black the doubled e pawns going to
be helpful for giri if he can open this
diagonal and get the defile to go with
it there's always some tactics to keep
in mind but but this isn't the spiciest
position no it's a pretty stable
position Anish giri is relying on the
power of His Dark scor Bishop um there
will be stuff happening on the defile I
think the is going to be a major conduit
through which a lot of the action
happens White's going to bring a rook to
D1 black is likely to shift the queen
away from D7 because the queen is going
to be very vulnerable after a white Rook
comes on D1 so I think that Anish got
exactly what he wanted he's slightly
better maybe only very slightly but he
has a relatively risk-free position
where he understands the plans and the
subsequent moves are pretty easy to
make agreed and uh despite it being a
little tame it can get away from black
if you're not careful so Dennis takes
his time before playing the move Bishop
F6 which pins the D- Pawn to the bishop
on B2 all right I like it we'll come
back to it in just a moment a lot of
other options going on here uh reminder
that this one is completely deadlocked
but a match that has a favorite so far
is yon Naomi versus Ralph mov yon won
the first game and right now he's
uh kind of it's funny we got the same
piece conglomerate that we have in the
game between lvic and giri but a
different Pawn structure the
center and I feel like I know this is
going to sound crazy but I feel like Jan
and Ralph are essentially following one
of their games from the 2023 World Cup
their head-to-head match that one of the
games featured this exact Pawn structure
and that's why I think Ralph has been
playing so quickly it looks like a
pretty Pleasant position for black he's
got this Pawn on D4 and that pawn on D4
Danny is a very powerful Pawn because it
is completely clamping down it is
paralyzing it's viav on C2 as you're
indicating I think Ralph is better and
he needs to capitalize on this
opportunity he's up on the clock for the
first time in this match and how does he
increase the pressure on C2 does he play
A5 and Chase the queen away does he play
Bishop E5 and try to get the dark sored
Bishops off the board I don't know
no but you're right he is in control
though so he's he's going to take his
time choosing it he's earned that time
advantage on the clock almost three
minutes although now now down to about
two
so yeah A5 and B4 oh wow a move we
didn't even talk about G5 the The Rook
defends it G5 and we live where are you
canny we in here we love you James canny
but G5 hits the bishop wait a second
wait a second where does it go if wait
if it goes are we losing the pawn we
it's happening it's happening here we go
and the evalar can't decide do I want to
take this Pawn do I not because after
the Rooks are traded on C2 the problem
is that the D3 Pawn is hanging there's a
check on D1 that could potentially be
devastating I'm actually surprised that
the evalar isn't more drastically in in
Black's favor white has to be very
careful and he's given up another Pawn
on A2 this is coming off for yand pomi
the wheels are coming off let's let's
analyze it real quick just to understand
because that's one of those moments
where the engine probably has something
to teach us what was it apparently white
needed to take God and then find Rook
takes E6 what in the world and then
guess takes D6 and then Queen takes D6
giving up everything for E6 and even on
Queen D1 check white has Bishop F1 and
it's actually a complete mess because E6
and G5 are hanging no surprise yand pal
she doesn't find this but it's one of
those issues where the EV valard was so
deceptive it was making it seem like the
position was balanced but only if you
find this are you effing kidding me
instead it's rookie one and all of a
sudden mov grabs A2 and he's in complete
control we're going to see a deadlock
match after this let's go unbelievable
and here's another problem for white if
you grab the pawn on G5 the problem is
not that black plays A5 A5 looks like it
traps the queen but it actually doesn't
because the B5 Pawn is going to hang the
actual problem is that black is going to
stick a queen on C3 if Bishop takes G5
happens right now black will trade on E2
and stick a queen on C3 and Danny
White's position it just turns into dust
everything is collapsing the D3 Pawn is
weak the queen tradus out of the
question you're screwed if you're on
aishi I don't see a way to prolong this
game much less to get back into this
game and again just like we called out
game one where Yan palish won that the
Clock Was revealing in terms of how
comfortable the players were in this
situation Ralph mov is very comfortable
that Nebo decided to repeat their battle
from the event you mentioned and now yes
now mov is like well I'm I'm happy with
this position he's completely winning I
mean Jan with the white pieces I praised
his form and it's like every time I do
that I did that in ttis steel he lost to
we I do that here he gets demolished out
of the open and queen to C3 raled off
has to find the move Queen to C3
otherwise he's much better but the only
move which maintains a clearly winning
position is Queen to C3 yeah it's it's
always fun when the best engine move and
a knockout is a subtle offering of the
queen exchange andal MTO finds it what a
nice move of course Yan didn't want to
trade and allow the cwn to rush but as
you already pointed out the B3 Pawn is
going to fall the D3 Pawn is also Weak
by the way this is this is fantastic
position for black but actually I mean
if you play Queen takes D3 here the
engine is giving Queen takes B3 which is
a a viable move but Queen takes D3 is a
more natural capture in my mind because
it creates a pass Pawn on D4 maybe Yan
is setting up that exchange sacrifice on
E6 followed by Queen takes D6 maybe that
is Yan's only path to complicating this
game so Ralph met off doing a great job
just pausing and saying wait a second I
know how tricky yand pishi is let's
eliminate any unnecessary counterplay
and any unnecessary adventures in this
position
y well as we can see from the other
games most of them are pretty deadlocked
so I think we'll stay right here we'll
take 30 seconds to take a closer look at
these players in their setup again Jan
having his first bad game maybe of of
this match but he still looks pretty
good in that chess.com swag and by the
way you see that does I haven't been
able to figure out what's on the wall
behind y to the left I don't know if
it's a samurai sword or something have
you been able to
see yeah it's some sort of
contraption that features a sword I
think that's the thing that's sticking
down into the floor in the direction of
the floor I suppose I mean I hope he
doesn't have to use it on a daily basis
CU I definitely stay away from y as it
is due to his strength on the board but
I mean if he's going to use that sword
then I'm staying away from him off the
board as well well I'm definitely
staying away from he loses this
game Peter Leo's commentary obviously
people people often spot the sword
behind him in this case we've got a
sword there for yawn I love it I love it
all right well
uh this is a big moment mov kind of
feels it even if he hasn't calculated it
fully yet Queen takes B3 or queen takes
D3 just to reminder Queen takes D3
there's this sacrifice on E6 and things
are going to get wild and it all works
by the way because Bishops move
backwards there is no Rook coming to C1
make sure you you keep that in mind so
all right we haven't checked on any
other games really this round besides
the one we started with that was loic
giri it is headed toward another draw
I'm just going to quickly flash it looks
like Dennis's Dennis's plans to be a
menace continue here uh
I I guess I'll go to for rouja artmia
that one's opening up a little bit
unless you have another one you want to
you want to hop into no this is good and
I just want to shout out Dennis La kind
of drawing from a position of strength
he was up a pawn in that position and
Gary had to win that pawn back so I mean
really impressive stuff Dennis going
down the pre-match plan that I outlined
you want to make three draws you have
the white pieces in the final game I
mean you've got a great shot of
upsetting Anish G that will be a game to
watch okay speaking of games to watch
we're getting a bunch of Trades and are
we going to get another quick draw in
this game and will that be three draws
in this
match it will be as well it'll be a
third draw they're currently dead like
why why couldn't the bishop take E1 I'm
sorry I gotta I gotta get this out of my
out of my chess play backing up to
analis I'm actually not totally sure no
it oh okay I was looking at this and saw
Queen takes first no but then if Bishop
C5 you have this what what oh my
God what a move that's amazing King
takes F2 Queen H4 check now that is not
a Desperado that you see every day Danny
wow and now you're able to move your
Rook away and black is up the exchange
wow great find wait so what so what was
the move then if Bishop C7 Knight C7 not
Knight
E7
aha okay
okay but okay and it's complicated it's
not like white is winning but has to
give the exchange back it's like it's
like when you're reading the chess
informant and they just give the
evaluation interesting at the end of the
line you're like someone got a little
tired and lazy because this is exactly
this this is not a position where you
can just end your analysis either way we
didn't get that line my brain feels
better if possible and we move on to the
live
position okay so a lot of trades on the
horizon here blacket sack the Queen uh
on C4 Queen takes C4 is uh I'm actually
predicting Queen takes C4 Rook takes C4
Bishop takes C4 Bishop D2 Rook d8 we
might get like a complete fizzle out
here if black takes on C4 which I think
is gonna
happen Queen takes C4 a massive exchange
by the way you talked about loic's plan
to just get this thing down to one game
it's continuing to work we have
officially seen a draw in the game
between and their third draw in a
row great stuff for Dennis honestly
having the day of his life right now and
Alli res fua big moment here Queen takes
C4 is going to lead to a mass
liquidation because white is going to
give the queen back up mean we could
show this line but I think we might see
this line on the board um so either way
this one is most likely to end in
peace okay then maybe we'll let the game
continue in peace and go over to Sam
Sean's last chance with white remember
he's down a game he lost the first game
in this match with white Wesley so doing
doing what he likes to do which is Win
rapid chess games probably winning more
rapid chess games than anyone on the
planet not named Magnus Carlson these
days uh and I I again I like his
position as black he's just been
Untouchable just in his position again
so solid no weaknesses if anything black
is probably in the driver SE
here I agree I agree black is in the
driver's seat
E6 kind of a pretend weakness but white
lacks the Firepower to really take
advantage of it
and just don't don't sleep on my ability
to grab this Pawn when I say my I mean
Wesley so the Royal we the Royal Wii
Danny wrench doing business as Wesley so
it's like when you buy ticket it's like
I wanted to fly Delta Airlines not you
know zebra air doing business as Delta
Airlines like Danny wrench doing
businesses Wesley will grab the pawn on
A4 right now of course the Knight on D6
is in White's line of fire I think the
other big question is does Wesley
actively try to prepare E5 or does he
basically adopt a waiting strategy does
he play Bishop takes D3 Rook takes C3
move the Knight away from D6 Knight back
to F7 comes to mind Knight to C4
excellent move
and I think Wesley is going for the
bailout here which is big trouble for
saman I me to win with black on demand
against Wesley so he's the worst guy uh
to have to win on demand against
especially with black I'm I'm still
reeling from the comparison of Danny
wrench to zebra Airlines like just
absolutely hey it's a
compl on the bingo card this is why we
need to get prop bets going in chess
prop bets based on the moves played prop
bets based on what the commentators will
actually say Okay Wesley not making it
so simple decides instead of trading on
D2 into the major piece end game he's
ready to rock by the way what if if
takes are you what piece are you taking
back with okay he answers the night I
was GNA say you had you had every option
I think almost to take back with
whatever piece you wanted gains a
Tempo Knight G6 Knight C6 Knight D3
another fancy liquidation what a move by
Wesley and that leads to a bunch of
Wesley is so sharp today I mean you
could just feel it in his play he's not
missing a single detail he's completely
in control of these games and this one
is heading in the direction of a draw I
mean Rook takes E7 Queen takes E7 Sam
could also give a check on B8 with his
Queen but I would not keep the Rooks on
the board here because that could only
backfire in White's Direction by the way
how's that M up game going yeah
completely agree again this is why
Wesley so was not chosen by anybody
similar to the first round of play if
you're just joining us remember the
higher seeds get to choose their
opponents but Wesley so is playing Sam
because all the other opponents were
chosen and Sam was stuck with uh you
know objectively may maybe maybe the
best rapid player second best again you
can't say that with Magnus Carlson but
uh he's he's so tough that's why
Wesley's doing well mov has been tough
in this game looks like he's going to
even up this match versus nepo look at
this position two pass pawns one of them
will become a new lady and we're down to
the final game on demand Victory with
black pieces against nepo just another
day in the life of Ralph mov like I said
he is just such a nasty opponent he
never goes away he's super experienced
and he's got this incredibly sharp style
that yeah when it backfires it can look
ugly but when it works it looks magical
and in this game it looked magical okay
what is Nea doing A2 and resign just A2
A2 and resign but he only had a minute
to figure it out you said when it when
it doesn't work it is ugly and that's
how the first game looked but this is
just this is just over I say we go we go
to the the other matchup where someone
is is is pretty much fighting for their
life and that is sel tur sakin he
blundered his Queen at the end of the
last game if you missed it so he is down
one and a half half to josam a guy that
was a nightmare for everybody in the
play Yesterday um excuse me NEPA
resigned by the way yeah NEPA resigned
we move
forward okay
and okay this is probably I'm trying to
figure out who is the side that's
pushing here I mean obviously
objectively it's a draw in a bullet time
scramble I would probably take the side
with a knight and the side with a pass
Pawn which is black but look at Jose's
clock he's got three minutes on his
clock this is gonna be a draw yep which
is you know not the worst thing for Jose
Martinez but even if you're Samy V at
least you get the white pieces with your
last chance to tie things
up Samy Samy V is that his new nickname
I mean at this Phi look svil tah hakin
not that not that we you know we can't
pronounce names good on this show the
point is Samy ve just rolls off the
tongue a little more effectively plus
that look he's got going I feel like he
could be an extra in a in a in a good
Fellas movie they're bringing
Ghostbusters back why not bring back
good
was no sell that's a pretty badass name
and he's a great player but he has his
work cut out for him looks like they're
repeating moves I don't think there's
any point in white trying to pretend
that you're playing for a win here
Jose okay Bishop A5 I'm sorry for black
that you're playing for a win here you
have to go back to C6 and keep defending
your pawn and for Jose he's actually the
one trying I think he's looking at
Black's clock and he's saying listen I
have nothing to he's trying to go King
G3 Danny and H4 and expand on the king
side and it could get a little bit dicey
for black if sell is not
careful completely agre this is this is
the kind of thing that josam is known
for doing he wins a lot of games in time
scrambles a very mini Hikaru as he kind
of said on the show yesterday that he's
learned from a guy like Hikaru to
persevere and to never give up it paid
off yesterday when he saved a dead LOF
dead lost position against Nakamura okay
this is going to end in a draw very good
move F five here from somville but uh
speaking of draws vladislav timv and Ali
Resa fuia Drew their third game so they
are they are on a path toward
Armageddon wow three draws there three
draws in giri versus lavic and not for
lack of trying I mean all of these games
have been very combative they've come
down to essentially bare Kings but
that's just how evenly matched the
players are and vladislav artm is one of
the hardest players to beat period I
mean that guy is the kind of
stereotypical Russian School Boy Player
I mean beating art you requires just an
incredible concerted effort I still
think f is the favorite in that match
but yeah as I always say anything can
happen in one individual game so if
you're the underdog you're really happy
that it's coming down to a single fourth
game completely agreed we talk about
timia being so solid we've talked to him
we've talked about about Wesley so being
like that too a couple of guys whose
style are it's just like built for fast
time controls because they don't beat
themselves they don't blunder and
everybody blunders in Rapid chess and in
Blitz chess but guys like AR timia Vin
so are just built different they are
built different and by the way speaking
Wesley so being built yeah we gotta go
over to that game Wesley so oh my God
he's about to end this match right now
wow somehow he was able to win and he's
about to Checkmate Sam Sean Queen E1
it's mate in three Queen G3 and Knight
D6 is mate wow he wins the
match two black so getting it done claps
his hands together he gave a little bit
of a dance there was that a little so a
so Stutter Step the so swing I don't
know what that was but you see that he
kind of did a little little hop skippity
when he got up listen I'm really happy
to score this Victory it was an
incredible win two with the black pieces
against none other than Sam Sean Sam
Sean is known for his opening
preparation but he got disarmed and
dismantled and dismembered in this match
he did disarmed dismantled dismembered
of course it's difficult when you're
facing Wesley so but the only matchup
still going we're going to check in what
H okay yeah there was a four gun at five
Rook ending draw this one is going to
give Samy V one last chance with the
white pieces he has to win on command in
the next game versus josam
uh we pet out to a draw but you know da
as I stretch my back you know we give
shout outs to secret lab we appreciate
their sponsorship of the Champions chess
tour we love these chairs because they
do have great lower lumbar support
they're so helpful but some people use
secret lab chairs in different ways we
have Wesley SS permission to show the
angle don't you stress this is our fair
play cam showing that Wesley
God Wesley loves the angle that that
secret lab chair provides apparently
that laptop needed some back
support I mean this is I'm my posture is
pretty decent but I literally think this
is making my back hurt Danny I don't
know in what world this is the setup
this is the ideal setup that causes
Wesley to play his best chess but
clearly it is and clearly he is playing
his best chess right now so I'm not
complaining more of this
please he does it all the time I mean
we've seen him be crouched in on a
massive monitor where the board was Tiny
for those who remember our Fairplay cam
shots from from a couple years ago now
he's switched to using the secret lab
chair in creative ways I mean I don't
know that he's ever tried it because if
you tried the pillow if you I mean these
things are made to sit in you know
Wesley sit in the chair okay da results
we got some must-win chess for Samy V
SEL tah hakin everybody else is is on
path I guess to get yet another draw and
take it to Armageddon of course besid
Sam Sean who has already been sent home
I mean we have a lot of potential upsets
in the making Ralph mov climbs back with
a win with the black pieces he's got the
white pieces Ralph very dangerous with
white Dennis lvic I've been talking
about him all day and deservedly so he's
pulled off three draws against Anish and
he also has the white pieces and I think
a great shot at scoring an upset and
fuja versus artmia total toss up
impossible to predict these games have
been extremely evenly matched so that
that one might make a fourth draw going
into an Armageddon and I certainly
wouldn't complain if we saw our first
Armageddon of the day my vote my
prediction Danny we're going to get at
least one Armageddon if not two I I
would be shocked at this point if we
don't we have three matches with
Armageddon potential there's an isiri
who's taken on the young Dennis lavic we
just saw vladislav artmia the the Chuck
Norris of the Soviet the modern Soviet
Chef school I don't even know when and
how he got that nickname but Ali Resa
fua really nice display very well
organized there on that uh that shelf
behind him Gucci Resa ready to bring it
better than nobody let's see what he can
do with
white very good okay D4 D5 and he has
settled into
a long think in this very new and
unexplored
position okay choosing very interesting
gamut
C4 riveting Danny this is a fascinating
opening I think KN C3 is actually
novelty I'm not seeing any games in my
database riveting riveting Queen's
Gambit chess here by the way maybe we
should send Wesley one of these other
secret lab chairs I have so if he has
two maybe he'll sit in one while he uses
the other one that might be the secret
any we'll talk about that with the team
later we see The Confident Swig of water
you're confident when you're on move
three in a Queen's Gambit that is for
sure okay vladislav kind of burning some
clock here deciding what to play of
course Knight F6 is the main move but
it's not the only move and again they
get this Carl's B Pawn structure which
we saw in game one of Vincent kimer
versus Wesley so in that game we saw the
move Bishop F5 Queen F3 and we saw this
very fashionable ending of course Bishop
F5 is not the only move you can play
Bishop B7 Bishop D6 has been pretty
popular recently H6 and Bishop E6 um as
well and vladislav plays it in the most
traditional way Bishop comes out to E7
this is how the Old Masters capablanca
alakin even Stein it's this is how they
played uh the Carl's Bad and there's
nothing wrong with that and this is how
we might get the middle game I was
talking about in that early kimer versus
so battle the one we didn't get where
White's going to launch a minority
attack which is to advance the two
versus three hence why it's called the
minority white wants to get the move B5
in some positions or okay the Knight G2
development is revealing that the other
plan is these F3 and E4 sort of slow
play to change the structure in the
center of course after you've castled
and connected the Rooks and A5 is a move
that designed to slow down that Minority
attack for white so as as I was about to
say Wesley as da said this is a very
very commonly traveled Road both sides
know what they're doing in this
traditional
qgd yeah A5 grabbing space on the queen
side preventing white from as you're
saying engineering the minority attack
with B4 now the move Rook to E8 in many
cases you actually see black jumping
into E4 with his Knight so don't be
surprised if you see the move Knight to
E4 even in response to Queen to C2 if I
remember correctly Knight E4 is a viable
option which is why white sometimes
plays an early F3 and F3 is a
traditional plan for white F3 to prepare
E4 but Ali Resa decides to play it in a
very kind of very tame very plain
vanilla fashion we're going to get a
long positional struggle here most
likely yeah long positional struggle
Rook
C1 just uh kind of asking oury of what
line he wants to choose because you can
go for the knight4 lines but that's a
very forcing and committ committ move to
make so perhaps artim is also going to
continue to to sort of play chicken here
and find another developing move before
you commit in fact Knight seven just
sort of slow jam
yeah okay yes very kind of you know
strategical
battle Knight E4 maybe very interesting
move I
think sorry
please waiting for it I wanted more I
wanted more I was I was waiting for how
interesting that impression was going to
was going to get um some positions you
have to take the Sasha voice right that
helps you play better chess you got to
do it um Knight H5 the other the other
other way to force the trade of the
Bishops it guards G3 so white is less
likely to exchange there if the if the
capture on E7 occurs which it does
you're not allowing the second capture
on e4 where white can maybe force the
structure towards something that he
wants so okay deadlock for a reason
let's move to a game that has a little
more Dynamics going on mov with teeny
Edge against nepo in this one okay yes
so we have a bunch of minor piece trades
already we might get another one on B6
white essentially can take on B6 on
demand so this is kind of a weird
Italian sort of structure with that
semiopen f file now typically I like
being on the black side of these types
of positions because you have long-term
chances on the queen on the king side um
one maneuver that you might see is Queen
D7 to F7 and then the knight from F6
might jump in uh to F4 via H5 but with
so many minor pieces already off the
board I wouldn't be as scared as I
normally am of getting caught uh in an
attack if I'm Ral mov yeah position is
equal I I don't even really believe that
engine eval point4 I would guesstimate
that this is essentially a dead equal
position and if more pieces get traded
here we might actually see a peaceful
result but knowing Ralph MAV he's
probably going to go G4 or C4 or
something for
and we will see complications here for
sure G4
C4 I mean heck sometimes you can still
go for D4 not right away there's all
kinds of
fours available here King H2 is a nice
little flexible
move but we're going to stay flexible as
far as the game we're committed to we
haven't checked on Dennis loic and Anish
giri apparently these guys are just yeah
they're just dead set on Armageddon um
you know depending on how how things
shake out we might have an opportunity
to interview one of them we'll see Anish
giri or Dennis lvic
just neither side blinking and we might
be headed toward the ultimate tiebreaker
sudden death chess
Armageddon which again I think the the
longer this match goes on uh the higher
the chance of something crazy happening
Dennis lavic would be happy with an
Armageddon but actually I think Anish
giri might be a tiny bit better here
just looking at this position from a
basic standpoint what are the pros and
cons of both sides setup black has the
pass Pawn on C5 right and black has a
very nice Rook on B5 which could
potentially infiltrate the second rank
so I actually think that Anish should
invest some time seeing if he can maybe
put a little bit of pressure on Dennis
even just from a psychological
standpoint going into the Armageddon
from a position of strength but
realistically I think the likeliest
outcome here by far is once again a draw
which will put us at four draws in a row
between these two players Dennis laic I
continue to be impressed by this young
man and the way that he's able to hold
uh super GMS pretty effortlessly it
seems you can easily confuse laic D
Danny for a super GM himself the way
that he plays the maturity and the kind
of measured approach that he has Knight
F6 though is a great move and Anish giri
is going to try to push this position
and play for the advantage he is not
just trying to bail out into a draw just
yet I like it okay but maybe you've got
Dennis lovic this guy this guy as you
said he sent hiar home fans that are
just getting here now are uh are
surprised by that you thought you could
show up late and still catch all the
drama shame on you get here earlier
we've already had some incredible action
some shocking shocking upsets and uh the
chessable Masters rolling on here
kicking off the 2024 Champions chess
tour Knight F6 is played I want to go to
a game that I think has a little bit
more fire still left in the cannon Queen
to E3 was just played by Samy V and he's
also way down on the clock D5 that's a
committal move in this sort of Hedgehog
kind of structure josman ready to strike
but it's an excellent move and the point
of D5 this is actually a typical idea in
this line that Queen on E3 is incredibly
misplaced what do you want to do you
want to open up the E file in order to
exploit the awkwardness of the queen so
if white pushes C5 which is I think what
terak was relying on I think after E5
Danny the position explodes and not in a
good way for white I mean white just
kind of collapses there C5 E5 let's say
white plays DT C5 you know how bad is
this it's pretty darn bad after Rook
takes C5 white also drops the C5 Pawn so
that's out of the question if you don't
play D takes C5 well not only does black
threaten e takes D4 but black also has
the positional threat of pushing the
pawn down to E4 and white is in huge
trouble here right out of the opening in
a must-win game let's not forget not
only does he need to turn this game
around he actually needs to win this
game it's looking really Grim in the
early going less than 20 moves in for
sell Sammy B might be going down and
just to continue that line da pointed
out at this point black could trade
everything trade everything and just win
the pawn for
frit which is free is as good as free
and it's funny you really gave a an
educational point there the D5 D5 is
often a risky move in these structures
if white can get C5 and keep a clamp on
the natural Central break but D5 is
really well timed a heads up play by jum
to say actually in this exact moment
it's the perfect time to strike you also
don't want to take I mean black can take
back probably a number of ways but but
they're all good in that situation and
if C5 isn't possible
then then as you like to say damn girl
and this is already looking really good
for J yeah I mean this is ideal position
if you only want to draw Knight D5 black
has complete control of the square in
front of the isolated Queen Pawn josam
is forcing another trade of minor pieces
uh Knight takes D5 he will play Bishop
takes D5 he will not play e takes D5 um
even though that seems to win a piece
but white has the knight jump to E5 yeah
and so Jose is going to take back with
Bishop he's not just trying to win the
game in one fell swop he's trying to
stabilize and increase his clamp over
the D5 Square he's also up four and a
half minutes this is going to take a
miracle at this point a a huge miracle
for Sam Bell to turn this game around
and win I don't see this happening Jose
is in killer killer form for the second
day in a row now again the birthday boy
won the Swiss yesterday got a little bit
of a gift from Hikaru Nakamura uh in in
a game that if Hikaru wins that game you
talk about sliding doors of the
Multiverse da Hikaru was literally not
blundering his night away from
practically clinching his spot in
division one right that game goes the
other direction when Nakamura blunders
that piece and instead josam wins the
Swiss gets himself that first round by
and continues on his fantastic form yeah
and of course SEL relatively speaking is
a good pairing when you consider some of
the other players in this round of
action but certainly not easy and S
himself demonstrated some great form
yesterday he is going to keep trying to
muddy the waters but I think after Rook
to C2 black could try to double Rooks on
the C file maybe White's only chance is
associated with some sort of kingside
attack that's why I really like the move
Rook to D4 he's trying to swing his Rook
over to G4 and Danny that Bishop on F1
it could ultimately activate uh to D3 so
there are some storm clouds that are
gathering around Black's King Jose has
to tread carefully he has to negotiate
some landmines on the king side but once
he does that I think he's got the
situation under complete control
nonetheless yeah and he's got plenty of
time to figure it out more than a
4minute Time Advantage is usually pretty
good when it comes to Rapid chess but
okay but okay we have other games to
look at Ralph mov and yanomi head head
themselves toward an end game
and kind of
deadlocked yeah I think this is smart
chess from nepo though because if you're
just tuning in nepo won the first game
in this matchup but Mya winning game
three means that the momentum is
favoring Ralph so you kind of want to
slow down you definitely don't want to
lose two in a row it tends to happen
from time to time so nepo is uh getting
himself a safe one here he'd be okay
with Armageddon perhaps at this point
yeah I think my prediction of two
Armageddon is a pretty well this game I
me the it's going another trade of minor
pieces
A5 which triggers further liquidation a
takes B5 a takes B4 the Rooks are going
to get traded white is temporarily going
to be up a pawn but White's going to
have a bunch of weak pawns on the queen
side and I think actually if anything
Yan might be drawing this from a
position of strength I think if anybody
has to be a little bit careful here it
might be Ralph mov who maybe should
consider a move like Rook F to A2 in
order to fight for control of the a file
he does play a takes B5 okay but I'm
curious how he negotiates the subsequent
phase of the game where Yan pishi might
try to put some pressure on White's
clock
also yeah and these Double B pawns
unless he thinks no but this a little
bit unpleasant yes there's no way he's
going to he's going to try toal that
maybe Rook A2 maybe Rook F2 but okay yes
I was thinking if he trades trades and
plays C4 I know that's crazy and then
tries to Corral the PA with the rook and
the Knight coming around to C2 okay
that's probably not what he has planned
but you
know okay not
even that's a fantastic move actually
that's a fantastic move Danny Rook to C1
is a move that everybody should notice
because why is he bringing the Rook to a
closed file because that file is to open
up and one of Black's biggest weaknesses
is that C7 Pawn which is contained by
The Pawn on B5 so Ral mov is
concentrating his forces on quickly
attacking the C7 Pawn he's actually
fighting for the initiative here in this
end game we've got some life some life
left in this end game this is not just
you know a dead draw it's probably
objectively drawn but both sides have to
demonstrate some Precision here to keep
the dynamic balance what a game and what
an endgame this is promising to
be agreed that's a fantastic
move take a SG of that water I'm out of
water
actually how about that LA game could we
check into that one see if that's still
basically within the realm of a
draw yes it is okay yeah that's it we
can move
on somil tah hakin and
oh o hold the phone okay you called it
the storm clouds were gathering yeah
now Bishop D3 Queen comes into G5 sack
sack mate no big deal I'm uh I'm feeling
it I'm feeling Samy ve in the comeback
the problem though Bishop D3 runs into
Bishop to H6 actually that is why Jose
brought his King to H7 he's not just
hiding cowardly in cowardly fashion the
king itself is participating in the
defensive effort Bishop D3 Bishop H6 was
unpleasant apparently that was still the
way to go Queen to G5 is a more human
move yeah but now Bishop H6 Queen
F6 and maybe Rook to C1 and White's
backside is also really really exposed
the problem I have with this line is
can't josam just repeat if you play
Queen F6 Bishop G7 uh all I need is a
draw bro
yeah and I mean svel realizes that he's
got no
chances yeah but I mean but that just
gives it up like I'm like this game just
ended and there's the guy who continues
to have an amazing chessable Masters we
appreciate him blocking out the gazing
Sun from the window behind him but I I'm
just shocked by how quickly that game
came to an end da that was just by the
way to quickly show we don't even need
an analysis board because the game's
over but the move was Bishop d three
Bishop H6 and then Rook to G5 thanks
computer go bleep yourself right I mean
like ah what like Rook to G5 was White's
best chance the point is if the Rook
moves double pin Rook takes H5 and you
can't take because the bishop can't take
because the Rook absolutely insane was
the path that Sami V had to find so okay
josham gets the dub we can move on oh
sorry he gets the dub in the match draws
that game else crazy
yeah we have wait a second okay we have
this ala versus OV game that we haven't
checked out yet 30 seconds 30 seconds on
the clock for artmia he has been
struggling with his clock for the entire
match but artv is incredible with his
last couple of seconds it's really hard
to get him to blunder and if you look at
this position Danny there's the prospect
of some Mass trades down the E file 20
seconds now on the clock for art this is
panic time if you're an artm fan Gotta
Move Gotta Move Gotta
Move Panic time got a move I love Fu's
approach even if it doesn't pay off and
we head to Army geddon because he knows
art is so solid look at the eval bar
artv hasn't blundered this game it's a
deadlock game but the clock is the
problem and I think if you have a match
strategy against artv it's like look
this dude is not going to lose on the
chess board unless he faces incredible
odds and awkward practic circumstances
play Fast get the dude under time
pressure and see if he blunders so just
giving a shout out to Ali Resa I think I
think playing quickly was a concerted
effort
here wow this is really high Action Now
Ali Resa trying to find a way to
complicate the
game and I don't know if he wants to do
anything foolish there is an increment
here so you don't just want to go for
some gimmicky trap attempt Knight to D7
and is there Rook takes D5 Rook takes D5
and in the event of a capture The Rook
on E7 is going to be trapped black is
going to be up a pawn black is going to
be down a pawn I was to say white wins a
pawn white wins a pawn at the end of the
line if fuia sees Rook takes D5 fuia
doesn't miss exchange sacks very often
he loves himself a good exchange sack
and we get the brilliant symbol I'm like
a kid in the candy store like
where's where where's my brilliant oh I
can't do that I was trying to do this
also yanish is putting Ralph omov under
some serious pressure
apparently
wow how do I get rid of them how do I
get rid of I can't I can't click now you
get rid of them seven seconds there we
go there we go I feel like I feel like
using annotate on a zoom call where like
you know it lets you annotate and then
there's no way to get rid of the
freaking ugly squiggly box you to try to
show anyway good talk good talk okay
time for fja to figure out a move here
his Rook on D5 is still kind of caught
in
limbo and I wonder what where he's going
to put that Rook Rook
D6 the black queen can drop back to C7
and continue harassing The Rook so this
is actually a three res game it's not
like oza is now completely out of the
woods he can totally blunder in this
position
agreed there's also I mean I I keep
wanting to make Rook takes D7 and D5
work it obviously if Rook takes D7 the
bishop can capture which means D5 is not
a fork of the minor pieces
so uh it doesn't quite work but it feels
like the tactics here should be okay for
white the eval Bar says they should but
with both sides under a minute don't be
surprised if we start seeing some
blunders
here okay this is going to be crazy 50
seconds now for ala fua he is burning
essentially the rest of his clock trying
to figure out where does he put his Rook
what does he do with that Rook on D5 if
he plays Rook F5 then he gives up the
pawn on D4 this is going to be high
octane action it's going to get crazy
just about
now by the way of the two matches that
we didn't see the Finish y nommi avoids
Armageddon delivering The Knockout blow
as black over Ralph mov
but an Nish giri and Dennis lvic have
officially drawn so you and I will get
some Armageddon chest so don't go
anywhere boys and girls we get free
chest it's Armageddon time no matter
what happens in this game Bishop takes
D5 Knight takes D5 looks like artmia is
running out of time he's giving up the
Rook on E7 I think go res is gonna win
this one dude he can even take B7 first
he does he takes B7 falling everything's
falling everything's falling yeah this
should be winning this should be
winning jeez
geez okay now oza has a technically
winning position maybe he didn't make
the most of this though maybe he didn't
make the most of this and now artv has
got some chances to hold on to this
position he's up two pawns but they're
not the healthiest of Pawns the D Pawn
is isolated the B Pawn is
backward one second you gotta move okay
Gotta Move Gotta Move Gotta Move Gotta
Move
Queen C5 try to trade Queens Queen takes
B2 Queen takes A5 Rook takes D4 doesn't
work black gets checkmated yeah queen5
he's gonna offer the queen exchange and
keep the a pawn I think fua is figuring
it out yeah I think white is going to
win you know what the right switch is
Rook G4 flip the script and go for mate
and all of a sudden the queen and Rook
are out of play oh he doesn't see it
Rook G4 was winning Rook G4 still G is
again but he's just going to push his D
Pawn he's just going to push his deep
and this is just winning I mean unless
he blunders his Rook this is over he's
got it he's it's in the bag H4 bold
strategy cotton it was a bold strategy
from fuia to just get the game in time
pressure where timv the often perfect
player is finally able able to blunder
incredible wait a second speaking of
blunders there's a made on G2 no resigns
there's a made on
H4 timv goes down to Ali Resa fuia which
means every one of our matches is done
and only one of them goes to Armageddon
that of course is Dennis lvic versus
Anish giri too incredibly solid players
big surprise nobody blinked here uh
obviously all the Gary fans get mad when
we mention four draws but it's also a
strength of his that he's so hard to
beat we'll see what Armageddon has da
wow it's going to be a fascinating
Armageddon Dennis lazic doing everything
that he's got to do to set himself up
for success but now he's got to deliver
in this Armageddon match I voted for two
Armageddon we're going to get one
Armageddon but I ain't complaining
because what an Armageddon it's going to
be between Dennis laic the Bellar
Russian Phenom and of course Anish
giri as you can see the other matches
ending in regulation josam Jose Martinez
Builds on his form from yesterday he won
the play in Swiss on his birthday he has
officially punched his ticket to D1 y
PNA she beats Ralph mov you just saw
fuia take down timv and Wesley so didn't
even need a fourth game to get the job D
versus Sam seian but we will have
Armageddon you said you said if you're
Dennis lavic this this is part of the
strategy you beat Hikaru Nakamura in
some ways you could say Hikaru Nakamura
kind of beat himself there obviously
hikaro didn't have his best form today
but in this one you had a plan which was
to stay solid and take it all the way
take it to the distance against yeah and
you have a plan you're adhering to it
now you need a smart bid you need to
keep your composure and let's see if
Dennis levik's incredible run is going
to continue Danny he needs a little
break he needs a breather but this is
going to be high octane Armageddon
action and I'm glad that we'll be able
to focus on one game you know feels like
a big relief right to focus on one game
and we get a break right now which also
gives us some relief or at least one us
cuz apparently as I throw to a break
I've just been informed that I'm going
to be hanging out for subscribers only
in chat I'm going to ask a question and
the first chatter to answer is going to
get a one- Monon Diamond membership so
what's going to happen is I'm going to
throw to a break I'm going to run
upstairs to the bathroom I might even go
key I'm just being honest then I'm going
to come back and I'm going to chat with
subscribers don't go anywhere the
chessel Masters and Armageddon on the
other side of this
break
[Music]
whether you're on a train or on a plane
or you go completely off grid with
chess's offline mode you can now study
chess anytime anywhere and not miss a
day of training and when you're back
online you just synchronize and
everything is updated
automatically all right first game we're
going to play is rapid fire all right
I'm going to name a sport and you're
going to tell me who the greatest player
is basketball uh Kobe Kobe all right
baseball uh
shoot well the one who play at St Louis
Cardinals they have some young players I
think what Mike mintini a player I like
him I meet him what about what about
soccer Leonel Messi because he's very
consistent okay also since back in
college days he was already number one
and he's still okay he's still until
recently number one football my homies I
watch him I watch also his commercials
okay 10
yovic yovic all right I love it golf I
guess everyone says Tiger Woods but
there's this uh very pretty girl paig
spe all right I like it all right what
about uh
poker I only know Jennifer
shahadi yeah I only know her and Chris
CH so you hear that Jen Shah you're the
goat you're the goat of Poker all right
chess chess uh Danny rench okay come on
you're the best I appreciate it I'm
going to say Wesley so then you said
favorite right favorite or who's the
goat who's the goat goat yeah hard to
choose I'd say fisher for now but I I I
suppose the right answer is Carlson but
I'll say fisher because he's American
okay just
boxing I'll pick my boy KY oh I love it
yeah he he hasn't done it yet but he I
think he might be one of the greatest
ever when he's done probably yeah he's
uh pretty pretty good your favorite
movie well say Lord of the Rings first
comes to mind okay classic I can watch
it uh over and over again but I know I
like the the very the newest bat the
Batman Okay 3 hours though the latest
one so I like it yeah it's I think it's
the best Batman movie ever okay favorite
TV show is the crown a TV show The Crown
yeah it is yeah I love it yeah we're
going to go watch it right after this
tournament the the the latest season I
love that's great that's great favorite
author I'd say sam Shanklin if he writes
more books well that's the first thing
that comes to mind like I I really want
to read leby roseman's book so I'll get
there one day well on L I'll ask you
who's your favorite chess Creator uh
well hikaro I I I love uh his uh twitch
streams although since his switch
websites I've been following him less
but when he was in twitch like I enjoyed
watching his uh title Tuesday stream
especially like Blitz or classical
classical online or OTV over theboard
E4 or D4 E4 Fisher or Kasparov ah yeah
hard question but I go with Fisher at
the moment closed or open positions
open open positions Searching for Bobby
Fisher the movie or the Queen's Gambit
on
Netflix yeah it's a tough question but I
go with the Queen's Gambit
okay
[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
okay
Cataline it's the most exciting
happening in all of professional sports
sudden death Armageddon dodgeball I I
mean chess da nitzki alongside Danny
wrench Anish giri versus Dennis lazovic
da wo are you excited I am thrilled it's
going to be such an exciting Armageddon
dandis lzc has a chance to extend uh the
tournament of his life I mean defeating
hiar Nakamura and now oh so close to
taking down Anish giri but he needs a
money performance in the Armageddon in
order to make that
happen both players have submitted their
bids I think we know officially who's
playing which color but I won't spoil it
while we get that 100% confirmed let's
remind the fans watching perhaps for the
first time when it comes to Armageddon
how the stuff
works welcome to the most exciting
format in chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match win white
starts with 10 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black in those coveted
draw ODS let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence let the
Armageddon commence let the Armageddon
commence players bid for time as we said
in the explainer the winner gets to
choose their color and the time opponent
starts with 10 minutes that's the base
time the biggest difference is there's
no increment which means we will have a
decisive result because either someone
Flags someone wins or if it's a draw
black takes the victory da it's the
greatest thing of all time it's
armagedon chess it's Armageddon chess we
all love it it promises a decisive
result that is the genius of Armageddon
we know that we will get a winner at the
end of the game Danny and who that will
be remains to be seen most players they
usually like to be black in the
Armageddon format because they like the
extra benefit of draw odds but obviously
extra time is also extremely important
and when you're dealing with someone as
well prepared as Anish giri I mean you
don't necessarily want to face Anish
with the black pieces although Dennis
has done a great job of it so far with
both
colors yeah well we have the bid right
here you said Dennis has done a great
job and he did a great job in the bid if
what he wanted was drawing chances he
out bid Anish giri by 8 seconds
fascinating to see with the 10-minute
base time control how aggressive the
players are willing to get they all tend
to have the same meta whoever's coaching
these guys on the meta strategy of
Armageddon bids if there's like some
secret you know diety secret world
renowned trainer on armagedon binning I
always find it fascinating how close the
bids are in fact when we were in Toronto
da the amount of times we had the same
exact bid by both players was
fascinating but there you have it Dennis
lvic the ultra solid Dennis lavic will
get draw odds in this battle no pretty
incredible Dennis lazic 6 minutes and 50
seconds and uh he needs to play fast in
the opening because we have to remember
there is no increment in Armageddon this
is the big difference and this is what
makes it hard to adjust for the players
to Armageddon you're playing with incr
you're used to being able to drop all
the way down to a couple of seconds
can't do that now flagging is very much
on the table
Danny flagging is on the table in fact
it's encourage right we uh we like
things to get brutal here in the
Armageddon format the Armageddon final
game and tiebreaker Dennis lavic I think
I think he made the right call with
black and it's not just because I think
he's taking Anish giri out of his
comfort zone I think Anish giri would
much rather be in a position to be solid
and be black but because he himself
Dennis lavic just doesn't beat himself
he doesn't lose games because of
blunders so I think this was the right
practical call but we'll see maybe it's
a wakeup call for Anish giri that he's
going to have to play aggressive chess
and do the thing he's not normally known
for which is uh which is going all
out yeah um we'll see andiri has played
in relatively plain vanilla fashion thus
far with the white pieces and like you
said maybe a change of openings Maybe
one E4 instead of one Knight F3 or one
D4 like an's been playing so far maybe
that's what you need from the CEO of
chess.com he wears many hats but right
now he'll need to wear the hat of the
winner of an Armageddon game never an
easy feat to achieve talk about an April
Fool's joke we did that that I don't
know if we wish we could take it back
but if you Google chess.com CEO I'm
pretty sure Anish giri comes up before
anyone else which is fascinating for
years people thought I was chess.com CEO
it is not it is it is Eric uh co-founder
Eric is actually the CEO I've got the
madeup title it's what they give High
School dropouts who don't belong here
Chief chess officer
but Anish giri is the is the official
CEO by most people standards if you
Google it and uh there you go here we go
we are off we're off to see the wizard
it's KN F3 it is night of three and once
again it's a colie system which did give
Anish giri the kind of position that he
wanted uh in their second match game it
was a slight Edge for white nothing
ultimately came of it but in an
Armageddon game black has less problems
less time to solve problems that white
will pose him out of the opening this is
similar to what Anish had against Max
waram in their final game of T of Steel
yeah and we might be headed straight for
an iqp battle if the tension breaks and
black has an isolated Queen Pawn it's
Dynamic enough that you're you're
definely going to get winning chances uh
so that's good but IQs have the
potential to get real simple real quick
if we get this structure and black finds
a way to orchestrate D4 you can see a
lot of minor pieces traded so Anish is
going to be careful here maybe use his
time advantage to keep as many pieces on
the board as he can okay Knight E4 Big
Move by Dennis lazic now in the event of
a trade on e4 that's out of the question
for white because the D4 Pawn is a
potential liability white I think just
has to keep the tension castle and
Dennis laic brings the bishop out to F6
I like the opening setup here as he
pressures the pawn on
D4 agreed Town population us both
players playing perfect chess so far
100% accuracy for those who like to
follow along with uh with interesting
stats at chess.com events Rook to C1
played now it's a good move and after
you take E4 we're getting a big old
simplification a huge trade a massive
trade
I don't know Anish is okay with it
apparently
but if you take with a queen you're in
an end game even if you have a small
Advantage
I I don't know about this bishop B6 and
rook fd8 and I'm not even sure that
white is better here I mean the engine
is giving a minuscule Advantage for
white but see the problem is that lavic
has only spent 30 seconds he's gotten
almost all the pieces off the board and
now he plays the right developing move
Bishop e six Rook to C7 is very tempting
but it can be safely met with Rook to D7
and with every piece that disappears
from the board Dennis levik's defensive
task becomes easier and easier so I
don't know Anish is better he's got some
chances here but he needs to demonstrate
Magnus Carlson level endgame Precision
if he wants to carry this one
home you said it you said it best I
don't have much else to say I'm sitting
here racking my brain with how this goes
differently I think that you know some
players have openings in their tool bag
that they know they have to use for win
on command
scenarios I I you know if this doesn't
work out and Anish is going back to the
drawing board you have to be a little
critical about maybe not looking for
something with with more Dynamics you
know something a little bit trickier
this this is a pretty simple and it's
also an easy position for black to play
right because you look at the clock he's
he's only used a minute he's only used
the minute and the big question here is
going to be whether White's pass D Pawn
is ultimately going to make its presence
felt can you ultimately disarm the
blockade the black has instituted on the
bishop on D5 also The Rook on C7 is a
really unpleasant piece black is
containing black is containing The Rook
but it's still a really unpleasant
position so Dennis lavic has to watch
his clock I would trade on C7 and play a
move like G6 make some LIF so that you
don't have to worry about a constant
problem of back rank mate G6 and I think
black is more or less
okay yeah and not even a lot to analyze
here I think G6 is a great move it opens
up not just the lift but prepares for
the king to get involved in help and
what's the forcing way what is the way
that white creates something you're
you're probably bringing the king to
E3 but okay not a lot going on here
not a lot going on and Dennis lavic
chooses this moment to pause I think
he's thinking about e takes F3 but he
finds he finds the move G6 Anish giri is
probably going to bring his King up to
F2 anisha's goal here is to keep the
tension as long as possible milk Black's
clock down because at some point
flagging as I said Anish giri is not you
know a noted Flagger but if he's got
three minutes and his opponent has 10
seconds and you've got two Rooks on the
board yeah obviously is going to go for
the
win yeah it's interesting cuz I'm I'm
thinking about the other other strategy
here and you know I remember an
Armageddon battle that Anish giri lost
in an otherwise Tam looking Rook end
game of course you know what I'm talking
about nhel saurin against Anish giri
from the chess.com Global Championship
you and I were in Toronto so there is
something to the idea that there's no
increment let's get a rook ending where
yeah normally you would draw but maybe I
just put you in a position where I just
straight up flag
you absolutely and now it's Anish gir's
turn to take a longer thing King F2 is
what I was expecting maybe he's
considering F takes C4 Bishop takes C4
and then Bishop to C4 going after the F7
Pawn but that feels like it liquidates
the game even further and black really
starts to knock on the door of a draw
after Rook takes D4 in that
position yeah it's F takes Bishop takes
takes Bishop to C4 couple options there
you could take D4 for F7 you could play
Bishop D5 and at the end of the trade
though white wins two for one so you
probably don't want that Rook ending I
think although do you because if you
take B7 yeah yeah why white gets both in
time so so okay I guess this is worth
worth considering Anish is uh ultimately
declining doing it plays King
of2 okay on the board good move still
very much still very much a game still
very much a game and black still very
much in the defensive here e takes F3
but after G takes F3 Danny the bishop
can drop back to C6 and I'm not actually
sure that Anish giri will be able to
defend the D4 Pawn this is looking
really Grim right now for Anish he needs
a big mistake from Dennis lasic he needs
some sort of a nervous move in order to
Garner real chances here yeah let's
let's analyze that cuz I think it's it's
trickier than it first looked the best
move here according to the engine is
Bishop takes F3 but the reason is if G
takes as D you said Bishop C6 you can
play King E3 but here comes a draw and
the reason is that after check you can't
go to D3 because Bishop B5 and it's game
over exactly you go to D2 We just head
right back to d8 and you're in a similar
spot so and although maybe he can go to
C3 at the end of the
line yes I think this might be the best
chance and he's made a move yeah and it
is let's see what he's captured with he
has captured with he took with the pawn
but loic didn't go for Bishop to C6
instead which is fine nothing wrong with
King F I mean he's maintaining the
status quo and right now he's basically
asking Anish like where is the wind
gonna come from and now I would give a
check on E8 and go back to d8 or go back
to E7 potentially go up to E7 also
asking Anish where's the advantage right
because guess what there is none the the
time advantage on the clock is all but
gone
it's all but gone I I don't see this
working out for Anish Rook back to E8
the bishop end game is a dead draw black
has zero problems there Anish needs to
play Rook C5 he needs to just try to
outplay his opponent in at this point an
equal end
game yeah play
it okay going to try to keep the pieces
on the
board keeping hope
alive not really most likely a draw loic
look at the clock situation also Danny
it's now fully equalized yeah Mr lavic
sent hikara Nakamura to division two and
uh might be about to do the same to
Anish giri the youngster
incredible I wanted to say the youngster
from Down Under but he's not from
Australia the Bell Russian
youngster okay A6 now simply defend the
pawn and the key for Dennis is not to
panic here the key is not to start
feeling nervous not to start you know
spinning the narrative in your mind oh
this is how close I am just play chess
just play it as as you would any other
endgame and he is a fantastic endgame
player I think he's got this completely
under control he's now up on time King
E6 King D6 I think Anish needs to try
Bishop C4 at some point but it's all
kind of a one move threat I this is
amazing
agreed agreed agreed oh but okay but
okay but okay what I like where's the
where's the thre yes you could also
could have played Rook D7 but this is
simple enough and who's going to be
playing for a win here in a minute
probably black given that he's up on the
clock um I I don't like Rook C2 though I
okay Rook C2 is a very concrete move
maybe I do like it no no Rook C2 and
simply he's going after the awn okay I
don't yeah I mean I'm I'm I'm I'm
turning around the thought that all
black needs is a draw here and again I
think that a lot of this comes back to
the the great bid from Dennis lavic to
put giri in a position to win his white
not something Anish giri probably likes
to do and
amazing just amazing
clinical
like had start of this now look at the
clock he's down 40 seconds so Dennis
laic has the luxury of taking his time
and he's probably going to take the pawn
on A2 my guess is that we're going to
see Bishop C4 by an trying to get it
into something like an unbalanced Rook
end game but even the move Rook to A5
here just keeping the bishop on D5 I
think is good enough to hold the draw
amazing amazing and the eval bar
is only equal if white chooses the
forcing draw lines but reminder we're in
Armageddon here a draw and Denis lavic
wins anyway so don't be surprised when
that eel bar quickly shows that black is
winning when Anish giri refuses to let
the game end peacefully so just
fantastic chess a fantastic day from
Dennis lavic right now and I would say
the last hurdle right now is this Rook
end game because white is down a pawn
but white does have a rather menacing
set of Pawns on the que side D5 check
King to E7 and Rook B8 can be Tried by
Anan he is threatening the move C6 here
so okay Dennis needs to be a little bit
careful King D7 maybe just stop The Rook
from infiltrating to the seventh rank
yes on the board King
E7 just go back but okay by black also
could have just checked because if white
ever goes to E5 it's check made in the
end with F6 wow great spot
so I mean black could just check check
check and again if you're checked on D4
and try to hide that's F6 Checkmate wow
so okay laic doesn't go for it is C6
check a move no King C7 well D6 is a
move maybe you could try D6 and I feel
like it's gotten a little bit scarier
for Dennis lazic Anish giri knows that
objectively he doesn't have much but he
has to find a way to tighten the screws
make it as practically difficult as
possible for Dennis although D6 Rook and
then King D4 so I my vote is D6
here yeah yeah got to try it gotta try
try
it you're saying there's a chance he's
done it good move he does it okay now
maybe A5 Dennis can basically do nothing
here but that's always kind of hard to
make yourself do when you're on the
verge of panicking so still some work to
do for black Rook B5 allows King to D4
so you can't win the pawn directly and
you definitely don't want the king to
get to D5 that would be a problem you
could try to push A5 and go for a
race garyi hoping for absolute Fury
working our last subscriber's name into
the commentary here for some absolute
fury on the chessboard to keep the uh
the fire alive shout out to the 16 month
subscriber but all of a sudden all of a
sudden this is getting complicated for
Dennis Rook to C4 is an excellent move
though going after the C5 pun and
temporarily sacrificing actually a bunch
of his puns but as long as he can
eliminate the C5 Pawn I think he should
have enough to draw the
game yeah if C5 Falls D6 will come with
it and what's funny is even if somehow
white wins both of these Pawns in theory
this is also a drawn ending as long as
the king is within Striking Distance you
can't win with the split corner and
Bishop pawns okay that's not necessarily
what lasic is shooting for especially
with no increment but it is something to
keep in mind it is indeed and now 90
seconds for Anish giri as he desperately
tries to find a way to keep the game
going Rook takes B7 Rook takes C5 Rook
takes H7 lazic will just slide his Rook
over to D5 and now flagging is more or
less off the table and yiri investing
the rest of his time to figure something
anyway to keep the game going Rook D5
flagging is off the table for a niche
not necessarily off the table for Dennis
at this point I mean that's right he
uh I I mean okay you can take H4 you can
also play Rook D5 I think Anish even
knows that this one is
uh is Out Of Reach to expect a
dub I mean Dennis more than happy to
give up the G6 Pawn for the D6 pawn and
get a fidor position the last hurdle for
Dennis I would play G5 here and swing my
Rook back to H6 just go get rid of that
D Pawn you could also go Rook A4 and
Rook
A6 I mean I find it very difficult to
imagine a way that black could lose this
the only thing you should do is be
careful on the clock make a move also
good also great yeah simple
enough
yep Rook Retreats the rookes it way over
to
D6 and Dennis is not even give up his PA
Danny Dennis is not even going to give
up the G6 PA so that's it this is over
he doesn't need to Honeybadger takes
what he wants he gonna take D6 without
giving up
G6 and I mean he's 30 seconds up only
Dennis can flag his opponent barring a
rook blunder this is a
draw always a little
nerve-wracking always a little
nerve-wracking look at an nishe he's
doing his
best I love your I love your pure
excitement but speaking of excited
Dennis lazovic the kid sends home hikara
Nakamura not home sends him to D2 Anish
giri will join his uh his fellow 2800
Club member are we looking at a future
member of the 2800 Club Dennis lavic
gets the job done draws with black
pretty sure he's nodding to our fair
play Team shout out to the event staff
making it happen behind the scenes
saying hey Dennis you up for an
interview he's like sure I'll do it I'll
do it oh yeah Dennis Laz incredible
Danny he adhered to the exact strategy
that we outlined he took Anish giri into
a deep dark Forest he dragged out the
match and then he delivers Armageddon
with black the ease with which he held
Anish
amazing well he's got a style that we
always say is is perfect for these types
of fast time control events he gets
openings that he plays more often than
his opponents he knows the tactics
almost You could argue his strength is
even better because he's getting those
positions so often just doesn't beat
himself Dennis lvic showing why he is a
name that everybody needs to get used to
but all right get used to where you're
sitting because we're not done yet we're
going to grab an interview I think with
Dennis lvic maybe one of the other
players but either way we'll be back in
just a few moments with the final
moments of the chessable Masters in the
meantime apparently we're actually we
might stay right here
apparently we're not going to go to a
break okay no break D girl and no break
I don't know but we're at some
point going to either go to a break or
be joined by an interview I'm waiting to
be
told okay in the meantime very exciting
Armageddon that we had just now congrats
to Dennis lazic what's the word what's
the verdict now we can go to a break and
uh while we're at the break enjoy a
little behind the scenes footage The Man
Behind the internet chess boom in many
ways Gotham chess he's the internet
chess's teacher according to most and
also chess.com is creator of the Year
enjoy this content get to know Levy a
little better we'll be back with an
interview the final moments of the
chessable Masters when we
return
the goal is get you to a comfortable
spot in those first 10 opening moves and
just have you hit in that
gas That's all folks thanks so much for
checking out my E4 course here on chess
I do hope you
[Music]
enjoy I got introduced to chess because
uh my family
is obviously both my mom and dad's side
is from uh former Soviet Union uh and
it's kind of part of the culture there
so I was playing with my grandfather
when I was about five and I I I think
What attracted me when I was younger is
I just got the game I got the game
probably on the level how most modern
day Grand Masters got the game I could
see something once and I could just go
demolish adults kids uh and and for most
talented players that's how it is for a
long time they just obsessed over the
game I hate to compare it to to Art but
in many ways it is I find it fascinating
every day I can teach myself something
played it for 20 years and there's still
so much I don't know I can play Blitz
Games and I can make Masterpiece or
chaos with white with black what a time
to be alive you know because I still
have insecure chess teacher Syndrome
from 2019 when I was just going to
private lessons and nobody knew who I
was and I still remember those days and
like I very easily just think about them
and I I'm not I'm completely the same
guy I just happen to do it on camera
now last one Championship I was looking
at five streams at the same time like
getting all the information trying to
understand the position more uh like I
keeping in mind what I'm going to say in
the recap a couple hours later who who
said what that's the stuff that that I
really get excited by just knowing that
it was it was a good recording it was
funny it was I presented everything I
want to present uh that stuff I guess is
like a cycle that that gets me more
energy I really enjoy making a high
quality piece of content it is very
natural for me uh to do the presenting
like I'm not fake at all I think that's
one of the reasons I can I can stream
and stay sane but like sometimes even
I'm exhausted and after I record a video
I have more energy which doesn't make
[Music]
sense I feel good about the current
career I I don't spend a huge amount of
time being uh introspective about the
current career I I'm just working as
hard as
possible with me it's just me and the
camera which which is even I don't know
I wouldn't even argue it's more weird
that it's just me in a room from 2020
until now I'm still just some dude who
likes to talk about Chess and I just so
happen to do it in a uh in an exciting
way for a lot of people and obviously
okay my confidence has grown in
presenting and knowing that what I put
out will get watched which is you don't
have that guarantee when you start it's
very nice and it's not something I I
take uh lightly but at the end of the
day if you really break it down I'm just
a dude who talks about
Chess
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
another
video I've taken an approach in this
course where I will happily enter the
main lines of certain openings for the
first five or 10 movs before deviating
into something that's aggressive
interesting uh and will definitely
make
[Music]
oh
no
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
oh
the playin stage comes to an end after
two days of thrilling action we had a
Swiss we had some incredible matches
today he was alongside me the whole time
John janitzki Danny wrench here but now
we have another man joining us alongside
a youngster a youngster who is making a
name for himself by sending some of the
biggest names in the game to division 2
respectively Dennis lavic Dennis uh
welcome in thanks for joining us and let
me let me just ask you straight up uh
you and I did an interview in Toronto
you talked about your your cat bushka
can't wait to meet bushka is that where
bushka sits on the window right there is
that a cat pillow to behind you on the
left is that for
bushka yes forka
is bushka around can I meet
bushka no bushka in some as a as a
room okay that makes me sad but all
right at some point I'm going to meet
bushka you got to remember that instead
I'll just I'll keep mittens by me but
all right John you take it away well
Dennis congratulations uh two huge wins
um let's talk about your match against
hikaro uh what does it mean for you to
defeat hikaro is that a special feeling
and can you share your thoughts about
the match
overall yes of course I I won only one
games only one game against hikaro in
title Tuesday so of course
to to win two games it's it's a it's
very nice I mean in of course the most
important game was first he
I mean probably he mixed up something in
the opening but after H4 Queen F6 I I
didn't see a a good move for him and
after that
I I think I I played quite good and just
I was just up up a rook and so I I
managed to to convert this
position it was it was amazing you you
converted the position with e
and then you moved on to facing Anish
giri a super solid player but you also
seem to handle that match with ease was
it part of your strategy to be willing
for a bunch of draws if that was how the
match progressed were you already
thinking that hey I'll take my chances
against andish giri in the Armageddon
tiebreaker if that's if that's the
case yeah I think
when uh when you play play against
opening which is um you know play better
than you it's it's it's quite logical to
try to make some draws and go to the
Armageddon because it's improve your
chances of course
I I wanted to win some games but you
know I I didn't manage to do that and in
um
in last game I was a bit worse but yeah
I I managed to make a draw and in
Armageddon
I I think I didn't have many big
problems so
yeah uh Dennis you are playing Maxima
shag grv tomorrow another incredibly
difficult match up for you have uh you
had experience playing Maxim before and
what are your thoughts on the match uh
tomorrow yeah I I only played against
him in ton so I I have some good
experience because I I
won uh I won that mat and yeah
I I think I will
some I will have some chances so
I today I played quite um
quite well I think and I will try
to to do it
uhor
tomorrow you did you did play quite well
today Dennis we we wish you the best of
luck doing it tomorrow you don't seem to
get super nervous facing these super GMS
one after another and if you keep your
wits about you you know who's to say you
don't send another one home so
congratulations Dennis go uh go snuggle
with with bushka give bka my
best thank
you bye Dennis
congratulations as Dennis goes to uh to
see the cat the the legendary bushka we
probably need to get bushka a bot on
chess.com we've given we've given Ponch
the P the Meister Leon ronan's dog bot
why not buka but all right it's Vash the
grav lavic nepom nesi Martinez Carlson
so OMG oh I just saw that woo I just got
a little hot over here Wesley so Magnus
Carlson and then fedos of fuia I mean
I'll ask you to Circle A matchup but uh
who says that Carlson doesn't get sent
to the losers bracket tomorrow huh no
but this is going to be another
incredible day of action I'm looking
forward to nepo versus jpam nepo pulling
out that match against mov out of the
clutches of defeat and Carlson so that's
just become a classic at this point
Danny yeah not even that I'm rooting for
Wesley but think when you look at a guy
who's probably going to be a little more
fresh you look at Carlson but if you're
looking for a guy who's already got the
Kinks worked out we know that Magnus
historically starts slow da that's a
nightmare matchup like to me I again I
don't know if the players are still
choosing their
opponents and if Magnus chose Wesley I
don't think so because NBL actually won
the the last event the AI cup of last
year so he was the top seed so what
we'll get a little more info on that of
course when I say Wii I mean the Royal
Wii it'll be David how Tanya sdev and
Robert hes you and I will be watching
his fans starting tomorrow da but I it's
awesome Magnus Carlson versus Wesley so
I guess I know what I'm doing on a
Friday I guess I know what I'm doing to
on a Friday but Danny I just wanted to
say it's it was a great honor uh to
cover the first two days of the CCT
season with you this was so much fun and
I'm really really happy that things
kicked off in such a combative um such
an action pack man really really sets
the tone for the entire season honestly
not just for this tournament but for the
entire series and I will be watching on
the edge of my seat tomorrow but I just
wanted to say how much I enjoyed the
last two days of the commentary I love
to Steel but with full due respect this
was action of a different kind I love it
well and before I let you go let me
remind everybody it is action of a
different kind but the action will
continue let's give everybody a look at
the full schedule you and I just wrapped
up the divisional placement rounds
starting tomorrow it's division play
until we get to our grand finals
remember we have a break now in the
schedules there's a rest day built in
for whoever punches their ticket all the
way to the Grand finals in division 1
they get to enjoy some D2 D3 action and
with some of the biggest names in D2 and
D3 whether it's hikaro Nakamura Fab
Carana so many others the stakes there
are very high because if you win those
divisions you really set yourself up for
the next Tour event to have an easier
route so so much chess ahead after that
D2 D3 broadcast day on the 6th we move
back to our grand finals somebody will
be making their way from the double
elimination losers bracket for a chance
to win it all can't wait to see who it
is I'm going to make a prediction I
think whoever loses the match between
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so probably is
still fighting on February 7th for their
chance back in the Grand Final it's
going to be it's going to be amazing da
but all right I'll throw the compliments
back at you it was amazing to work with
you you and I did it vid it we did it we
kicked things off here the 2024
Champions chess tour is underway shout
out to the whole crew our production
team the mods the family keeping it real
I'm GNA hang out and chat a little bit
as we take a break for my partner da
nitki this was the chessel Masters enjoy
Tanya and the boys starting
tomorrow
[Music]
pap
n
[Music]
he